GOOD MORNING EVERYONE AND
WELCOME TO OUR BUDGETS UP THREE
MEETING I APOLOGIZE FOR BEING
LATE BUT I THINK JUST ABOUT
EVERYBODY HERE KNOWS THAT. THEY
WERE IN THE.
AND EVEN KNOW HOW TO DESCRIBE IT
OF LEGISLATIVE EGG EGG BEATER.
AGAIN OUR BILLS OUT OF.
COMMITTEE OF WORDS IN THIS
WEEKEND IT'S
YOU KNOW.
CRAZY MAKING.
AYE OF MAY HAVE TO GET OUT BUT
AT SOME POINT DURING THE MEETING
AND PRESENT A BILL. IN THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE AS WE
MAY NEED TO TAKE A BREAK AT THAT
POINT BUT. RIGHT NOW WE'RE HERE
AND READY TO BEGIN AND LEADING
OFF THIS MORNING GUY WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR FROM A PANEL OF
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE BEEN. A
WORKING VERY HARD OVER THE PAST
FEW YEARS ON HOW TO ADDRESS THE
WHALE AND THE.
A A A A AD AND AND OTHER MAMMAL
ENTANGLEMENT PROBLEM THAT'S
OCCURRING NOT ONLY ALONG
CALIFORNIA'S COAST LINE BUT. A
ELSEWHERE AROUND THE WORLD.
AND WE OFTEN HEAR ABOUT THE
URBAN WILDLIFE INTERFACE IN THE
CHALLENGES.
THAT THAT WE FACE IN THAT
REGARD BEARS GETTING INTO
GARBAGE CANS MOUNTAIN LION
ENCOUNTERED AND. ENCOUNTERS IN
FRONT YARDS ARE PARK SIR.
DOES HAVE LEAVE ME HEAD ON OUR
HIGHWAYS BUT WE OFTEN DON'T
REALIZE THAT WE INCREASINGLY
FACE.
SIMILAR CHALLENGES IN THE OCEAN.
AND AS VAST AS THEY MAY SEEM.
IT'S A VERY REAL PROBLEM AND
THAT'S WHAT BRINGS US.
I HERE TODAY FOR A MORE IN DEPTH
DISCUSSION.
LAST YEAR THIS COMMITTEE MADE AN
INVESTMENT TO A RELATIVELY SMALL
AMOUNTOF MONEY ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO ASSIST WITH
EXPENSES THAT THE SMALL GROUP
OF.
LICENSED ENTITLEMENT RESCUE
VOLUNTEERS INCUR. THE
EXPONENTIAL INCREASE IN
ENTANGLEMENTS WARRANTED THIS
IMMEDIATE FINANCIAL RELIEF FOR
THESE EMERGENCY RESPONDERS AND.
AND.
MY PIN WE NEED TO DO MORE THAN
JUST INVEST IN RESPONSE WE NEED
TO TAKE PREVENTATIVE MEASURES AS
WELL. TODAY WE'LL HEAR FROM
EXPERTS IN THE FIELD ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND HOW WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO HELP.
SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO INVITE.
AT THREE UP PANELISTS.
GUERRA.
I HAD THOUGHT WE'RE EXPECTING A
MISTER NOAH OPPENHEIM A WITH THE
PACIFIC COAST.
FEDERATION OF FEOFFEES RUNS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WAS UNABLE TO MAKE
THE TRIP HERE TODAY.
.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT LEAVES
STURGES WHO WAS ON THE PANEL
WILL COVER SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT HE WAS GOING TO COVER. AND
TO US SO.
WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE THAT ONE
IS JUST TOO SELF INTRODUCTION
SINCE WE'RE RUNNING A LITTLE BIT
LATE. AND TO WELCOME HERE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS IMPORTANT
DIALOGUE.
VERY GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF MANY OF TIME THAT
CAME WITH THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
IN CALIFORNIA I RUN OUR
SUSTAINABLE FISHERIES INITIATIVE
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THE%
ISSUE OF WELL TANGLING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS.
IF YOU WANT OKAY MY NAME IS LEO
STURGIS I REPRESENTING SOCIAL
COMPASSION AND LEGISLATION AND
I'VE BEEN DOING WHILE LIFE
ADVOCACY WORK FOR THE PAST FIVE
YEARS. AND I'M CURRENTLY DOING A
DOCUMENTARY ON WILL ENTANGLEMENT
WHICH HAS LED ME TO.
FIND OUT A LOT ABOUT THE
SUBJECT.
THEM.
JOHN FEET TACOS FROM THEM
IRANIAN.
TOUCHED MINE IS STRONGER YEAH.
WE'VE DEVELOPED SOME TECHNOLOGY
THAT WE THINK COULD HELP.
PREVENT WELL ENTANGLEMENT.
DATA DAVE ANDERSON AYE RUN
CAPTAIN DAVE'S DOLPHIN WELL
SAFARI AND I ALSO FORMED ORANGE
COUNTY'S FIRST WELL RESCUE GROUP
AND BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS
ENTANGLING WELLS FOR ABOUT THE
LAST TEN YEARS.
GREAT OR WATCH PROCEED WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION PLEASE.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AGAIN FOR
HEARING US TODAY.
.
SO.
UNDER THE NORTH AMERICAN MODEL
OF WILDLIFE CONSERVATION OF
WILDLIFE IS A PART OF THE PUBLIC
TRUST AND CONSIDERED AN
INTERNATIONAL RESOURCE.
THE ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT
PROTECTS BLUE WHALES HUMPBACKS
AND SEA TURTLES.
AND THE MARINE MAMMAL PROTECTION
ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO
TECHNICALLY MAKES EACH
ENTANGLEMENT A VIOLATION OF THE
LAW.
HERE'S A MAP OF ENTANGLEMENT
LOCATIONS KNOW WAS LAST OFFICIAL
REPORT IS FOR TWENTY SIXTEEN SO
I'M GOING PRIMARILY OFF THOSE
NUMBERS BUT I HAVE SOME
UNOFFICIAL. TWENTY SEVENTEEN
NUMBERS.
THERE SEVENTY ONE REPORTED
ENTANGLEMENTS IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
ESTIMATES ARE THAT THE ACTUAL
NUMBER IS ABOUT TEN TIMES THE
AMOUNT.
I JUST BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE.
JUST PEOPLE OUT ON THE WATER
JUST HAPPENED TO SEE THESE
WHALES SO THEY ACTUALLY BELIEVE
THE NUMBERS TEN TIMES THAT. THE
NORTH PACIFIC HUMPBACK
POPULATIONS ARE STABLE HOWEVER
THE CENTRAL AMERICAN POPULATION
WITH ONLY FOUR HUNDRED ELEVEN
INDIVIDUALS IS IN JEOPARDY AND
FEEDS ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY OFF
CALIFORNIA AND OREGON.
AND ALSO.
TWENTY TWO OF THE TWENTY NINE
VERIFIED CASES INVOLVED THE
DUNGEON* CRAB FISHERY.
SO THAT HAS BECOME.
.
A AN ISSUE.
OKAY.
BERTHA.
SO ONE OF THE BIG ISSUES IS.
THE CONCENTRATION OF TRAPS
WITH STAGGERED SEASON OPENINGS
VESSELS FROM AFAR AS FAR AWAY AS
ALASKA CAN COME TO CALIFORNIA
AND FISH OUT THE DISTRICTS HERE
BEFORE RETURNING TO THEIR
DISTRICT.
FOR THE OPENING SO THIS IS ALSO
LED TO A DRAMATIC DECLINE IN
INCOME FOR LOCAL FISHERMEN. AS
LOCAL SPOTS GET PLUNDERED BY THE
US LARGER VESSELS
FROM OTHER DISTRICTS.
SO WHEN VERY ALARMING SITUATION
IS THE ENTANGLEMENT OF BLUE
WHALES THE LARGEST ANIMAL IN THE
WORLD WHICH FIRST OCCURRED.
REPORTED IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WITH
ONE BLUE WHALE THEN INCREASE TO
FOREIGN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND.
ARE THERE ARE THREE AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
SO THERE'S ONLY TWENTY TEN TO
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND TWO WHEELS
WORLDWIDE AND JUST OVER. TWO
THOUSAND ALONG THE PACIFIC COAST
TROUBLING FROM ALASKA TO MEXICO
IMPERILED.
POPULATION.
HERE WE HAVE A GRAPH WHERE YOU
CAN SEE THE ESCALATION IN
TELEMANN'S OVER THE PAST SIXTEEN
YEARS.
ON PRETTY MUCH BEFORE TWENTY
FOURTEEN WAS KIND OF HOVERING
OVER YOU KNOW AROUND BETWEEN TEN
AND TWENTY. WITH SORT OF A
DRAMATIC ESCALATION AFTER TWENTY
FOURTEEN.
AND WITH TWENTY SIXTEEN.
PICKING AT SEVENTY ONE REPORTED
ENTANGLEMENTS.
SO.
.
YOU CAN SEE HOW IT'S ESCALATED
HERE.
THE UNOFFICIAL NUMBER FROM NOVA
FOR TWENTY SEVENTEEN IS FORTY
ONE REPORTED ENTANGLEMENTS SO
THEIR HOUSE BEEN A SLIGHT
PULLBACK ALTHOUGH WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THE RECORDED NUMBERS
ARE REFLECTIVE OF ROUGHLY ONE
TENTH OF THE NUMBER OF THE
ACTUAL ENTANGLEMENTS.
THE NUMBERS ARE STILL ARMING.
HERE ARE ENTANGLEMENT REPORTS BY
COUNTY
SO FROM TWO THOUSAND TO TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN.
ON YOU CAN SEE THE NUMBERS UP
HERE.
.
AND IN TWENTY SIXTEEN FORTY TWO
PERCENT OF REPORTED
ENTANGLEMENTS WERE IN MONTEREY
COUNTY.
SO WE'RE SEEING. EXTREMELY HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF ENTANGLEMENTS IS
OCCURRING IN THAT ONE AREA.
WHICH IS ALSO THE NATIONAL
MARINE.
SANCTUARY.
I SPOKE TO FISHERMEN IN BODEGA
BAY WHO HAVE NEVER SEEN AN
ENTANGLEMENT AND THERE THIRTY
YEARS ON THE WATER.
I ASKED THEM TO SPECULATE YOU
KNOW ABOUT WHY THEY THOUGHT THAT
WAS THE CASE AND HE SAID THAT
THE CURRENTS WERE EXTREMELY
STRONG IN BODEGA BAY. THAT MAY
BE ONE REASON THAT YOU THE LINES
ARE TALKS.
AND LESS ENTANGLEMENTS OCCUR NOW
THIS IS SPECULATION BUT.
IT'S JUST ALARMING THAT SO MANY
OF THERE'D BEEN TENANTS DO A
CURRENT AND MONTEREY.
SO MONTEREY IS ALSO.
ONE OF THE SOUTHERN MOST
LOCATIONS WERE CRAP FISHING
TAKES PLACE.
AND ACTUALLY ACCOUNTS FOR
RELATIVELY.
A SMALLER CROWD HARVEST COMPARED
TO OTHER.
OTHER DISTRICTS.
HERE'S A MAP OF MONTEREY BAY
NATIONAL MARINE SANCTUARY.
SO COMMERCIAL FISHING IS ALLOWED
IN THE SANCTUARY HOWEVER IT IS
ALSO SUPPOSED TO PROTECT WHALES
THE FEDERAL DESIGNATION.
THERE IS ALSO A STATE MARINE
RESERVE FOR COME CRUCIAL FISHING
IS PROHIBITED AND THEN THE STATE
MARINE CONSERVATION AREA WERE
COMMERCIAL FISHING IS ALSO
ALLOWED.
UP THE STATE MPAS ARE CLOSER TO
SHORE AND LESS LIKELY TO HAVE
ENTANGLEMENTS OCCUR THERE BUT
THE FEDERAL MARINE SANCTUARY IS
A DEEP CANYON WORDS BELIEVE THAT
MOST OF THE ENTANGLEMENTS ARE
OCCURRING.
.
SO ROUGHLY TEN PERCENT OF EACH
FISHERMAN'S GEARS LOST EVERY
YEAR WHICH IS A VERY.
THE HIGHER UP AMOUNT.
HERE'S A PIE CHART SHOWING
CAUSES OF LOBSTER BAND GEAR WITH
THE SECOND LARGEST PERCENTAGE.
AS UNKNOWN.
I AS AN UNKNOWN BECAUSE.
SO EIGHT THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO TOTAL TRAPS WERE
REPORTED LOST IN TWO YEARS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA FROM TWENTY
THIRTEEN TO TWENTY FIFTEEN. SO
THIS IS NOT INCLUDE LOS TRAPS
THAT WERE NOT REPORTED.
.
SO YOU HAVE THE VARIOUS.
THINGS THAT ARE CAUSING THIS
WHETHER BEING THE LARGEST ONE
AND SORRY UNKNOWN CAUSES.
WELL AND THEN FOLLOWED BY
WHETHER.
CURRENTLY DISENTANGLE MEN'S ARE
HANDLED BY VOLUNTEERS WITH
LITTLE FUNDS AND RESOURCES THE
VOLUNTEERS ARE RISKING THEIR
LIVES TO GET UP NEXT TO THE
WHALE THE CUT THE ROPE OFF WITH
A KNIFE.
AND LESS THAN TEN PERCENT OF
ATTEMPTED DISENTANGLE MEN'S OUR
SUCCESSFUL.
THE CALENDAR CALIFORNIA
DUNGENESS CRAB.
FISHING WORKING GROUP PROVIDES
GUIDANCE AND RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE CRAB FISHING INDUSTRY THEY
HAVE CREATED A BEST PRACTICES
GUIDE AND THE RISK ASSESSMENT
MITIGATION PROGRAM.
HOWEVER PARTICIPATION
IMPLEMENTATION OF GUIDELINES BY
FISHERMEN ARE TOTALLY VOLUNTARY.
THEY CAN CHOOSE NOT TO COMPLY
WITH GUIDELINES IF THEY DECIDE.
AND ALSO THE PUBLIC IS NOT
ALLOWED TO ATTEND THESE
MEETINGS.
SO POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS.
ELECTRONIC TRACKING IS
APPEALING SOLUTION BECAUSE IT
WOULD BOTH HELP.
BOTH WALES AND FISHERMEN PLACING
TRACKING DEVICES ON BOOZE WOULD
NOT ONLY TRACK LAST YEAR BUT A
CONTRACT A WHALE THAT'S
ENTANGLED IN THE GEAR. AND
PROVIDE ITS WHEREABOUTS YOU
COULD ALSO PROVIDE DETAILED REAL
TIME DATA REPORTS ABOUT WHERE
TRAPS ARE SET.
NOW WE HAVE ROPE REALPLUS THOSE
ARE AMY OF ROPE WAS POP UP LUIS
AS AN EXAMPLE OF ONE HERE.
AND THAT'S NOT VERY EXCITING
OPTION BECAUSE YOU ELIMINATE THE
VERTICAL LINES IN THE WATER
PREVENTING ANY ENTANGLEMENTS.
I ALSO SEE THIS AS A BONUS TO
FISHERMEN BECAUSE.
THEY LIKE TO KEEP THEIR FISHING
SPOTS SECRET SO THIS WOULD YOU
KNOW PREVENT OTHER FISH AMENDED
FOR COMING INTO THE AREA SEEING
WHERE THEY HAVE PLACED THEIR
TRAPS SO I SEE THIS AS A BENEFIT
TO FISHERMEN.
AND ANOTHER POSSIBLE SOLUTION
THAT'S BEEN DISCUSSED IS
BIODEGRADABLE ROPE.
APPARENTLY THE.
MANY OF THE ENTANGLEMENTS OCCUR
MOST OF ENTITLEMENTS ACROSS THE
FIRST THIRTY FATHOMS OF THE LINE
OF THOSE OFFERS HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FEET OF LINE.
AND THOSE FIRST THIRTY FATHOMS A
ROPE COULD BE REPLACED BY A
DISSOLVED OR BREAK AWAY LINE
SO THAT'S ANOTHER.
IDEA THAT'S BEEN THROWN AROUND
AROUND.
FINALLY ANOTHER SOLUTION WHICH
ADDRESSES THE CONCENTRATION OF
TRAPS IS HAVING THE SEASON
OPENER ON THE SAME DAY ACROSS
EVERY DISTRICT.
THIS PAST YEAR SOME DISTRICTS
OPEN ON NOVEMBER FIFTEENTH WHILE
OTHERS OPENED ON DECEMBER FIRST.
CHOOSING ONE DATE WOULD BE A
SAVING GRACE FOR SMALLER LOCAL
FISHING COMMUNITIES
AS IT WOULD PREVENT LARGER
VESSELS FROM OUT FROM OTHER
DISTRICTS FROM FISHING OUT LOCAL
AREAS ROOF ROOF BEFORE RETURNING
TO THEIR DISTRICT.
FOR THEIR OPENING.
THIS GIVES LARGER FLEETS AN
UNFAIR ADVANTAGE.
THIS PAST YEAR I WENT OUT WITH
THE FISHERMEN TWO WEEKS AFTER
THE OPENING AND ALREADY THERE
WAS A HUGE DECLINING CRAB THE
FISHERMAN EXPLAINED HOW THE HOW
THE LARGEST HARVEST.
POTENTIAL TO MAKE THE MOST MONEY
IS RIGHT AFTER THE START OF THE
SEASON.
SO I REALLY SEE THIS SEASON
OPENING WITH IT WITH A HUGE
CONCENTRATION OF TRAPS BEING.
.
A REALLY ABOUT A BIG PROBLEM IN
THE CAUSE OF THE ENTANGLEMENTS.
AND SO HERE ARE VARIOUS PAPA
BUOYS WHICH WERE CREATED TO
SERVE THE NEEDS FOR IMPROVE
SAFETY IN THE WATER BY REMOVING
POTENTIAL DANGEROUS SURFACE
MARKER BUOYS AND THERE ARE.
VARIOUS.
REASONS THAT THIS IS DANGEROUS
YOU KNOW BOATS PASSING AT NIGHT.
CAN GET.
THERE PROP CAUGHT IN THAT.
WALES UNTANGLED THAT I'D SEE
TOWARDS UNTANGLED SO THAT WE
REALLY LOOK LIKE THE SPIDEY OF
POP UPS.
IN CLOSING ELIMINATING VERTICAL
LINES IN THE WATER WOULD AND
CALIFORNIA ENTANGLEMENTS.
FUNDING IS NEEDED FOR TESTING OF
THE VARIOUS OPTIONS.
OF EXISTING TECHNOLOGY WE WANT
TO TAKE FOR STEPS TODAY TO
DEVELOP A LONG TERM. PLANS
IMPLEMENT PROVEN TECHNOLOGIES
THERE ARE SOLUTIONS THAT EXIST
RIGHT NOW THAT COULD STOP WILL
ENTANGLEMENTS AND WOULD LIKE TO
URGE. ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
STATE TO TAKE STEPS TO SEE HOW
WE CAN USE THIS TECHNOLOGY TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEMS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND UP NEXT YEAR OF NEXT.
.
JUST A BIT OF HISTORY ABOUT.
PRODUCT THAT DUH I INVENTED.
ABOUT CITIES A GUY.
BECAUSE OF I.
ENTANGLEMENTS LE ONE NIGHTS
HAVE BEEN ON THE WATER AROUND
AND ABOUT WAS DISABLED AND
NEARLY LOST BECAUSE OF
ENTANGLEMENT IN FISHING
GEAR.AND.
.
PROBABLY A BAD I USE LYDA ALL
ACTUALLY DID SOMETHING ABOUT MOM
IDEA.
AND IT WAS BECAUSE OF.
THE APPLICATIONS I WOULD SAY IN
ONE OF THEM WAS WHILE
ENTANGLEMENT AS WELL UNITS STRIA
AND ALSO SAFETY REASONS.
WE MIGHT EFFORTS BACKING NAUGHTY
NAUGHTY AYE TO THE IT'S RYAN
DEFENSE DEPARTMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY THE.
FISHING INDUSTRY.
WASN'T INTERESTED IN AB
TECHNOLOGY BACK THEN.
.
NOW FOR VARIOUS REASONS.
AND.
WHO US TWENTY YEARS WE'VE BEEN
SELLING NOW POP UP BOYS TO?
?
A FRIEND'S PROM RESEARCH AND HOW
OR WHEN GAS.
WE MIGHT HAVE FOODS OUT TO THE.
U. S. DIFFERENCE THE PROBLEM IN
TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE.
AND.
SINCE THEN WE'VE BEEN SELLING
TO THEM ON AND OFF.
THE LAST ORDER THAT WE SUPPLIED
WAS THREE WEEKS AGO.
AND LUCK WAS WITH THE US RIDE
DIFFERENCE DEPARTMENT. WILL SAID
SO TO.
JAPAN MALAYSIA SINGAPORE.
AND.
BILL JUNE WHICH WAS GRAYSON WAY
AS WELL.
SORRY AT TECHNOLOGIES.
NO WE FEEL WAS BEEN PROVEN OF
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS.
PSYOP POP UP BOY.
.
IF WHOSE BRAIN USE DUH CERTAINLY
NOT WELLS WOULD BE ENTANGLED IN
ANY OF THOSE LINES.
WE'VE.
RESEARCH STILL BEEN INVOLVED IN
THAT MARKET FOR THE TWENTIES WE
HAVE SOME.
GREAT AUNTIES AND.
HAVE WE CAN HELP THE INDUSTRY.
WE UNDERSTOOD PROBABLY TEN
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO THAT.
THE MARKET DOES NOT EXIST ON TO.
SOMEONE.
SAYS THAT THE FISHERMEN REALLY
NAY TO USAID SINGS.
.
WE'VE INTRODUCED IT TO THE
FISHERMEN OF.
MANY HE'S.
.
AND THE RESPONSE WE HAVE IS A
IT'S A GREAT PRODUCT BUT.
NO ONE REALLY WHICH IS TO
COMMIT SAWS.
WE HE'D JUST DECIDE THAT.
.
THERE'S TECHNOLOGY OUT THERE
THAT DOES WORK.
AND COULD SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
SON.
.
IT. COULD.
THANK YOU.
IS SO.
WE WE DO DISENTANGLE MEANT WORK
UNDER.
NO IS A FLORIDA WERE ACTUALLY
TRAINED BY NO ADDED TO.
DISENTANGLE WELLS AND ON PART
OF THE.
NETWORK OF TEAMS.
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES THAT.
DO THESE DISENTANGLE METS.
AND.
I CAN TELL YOU IT'S
HEARTBREAKING TO SEE THESE
ANIMALS UNTANGLE WE HAD OUT WE
HAD A WELL YESTERDAY THAT WAS
ENTANGLED RIGHT OFF OF DANA
POINT.
THAT WE.
TRIED TO HELP BUT WE FAILED.
AND THIS HAPPENS OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
THE MONEY NEEDS TO BE SPENT ON
PREVENTION.
A I'M GLAD YOU GUYS ARE GIVING
US MONEY FOR.
FOR THE TOOLS AND EQUIPMENT OF
THAT THAT'S A BLESSING AND WE
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH.
IT'S BEEN NEEDED THAT WE HAD TO
SPEND OUR OWN MONEY FOR A LOT OF
YEARS TO DO THIS.
BUT.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A LOT OF
MONEY SPENT ON PREVENTION OF
THIS PROBLEM THERE'S.
JUST A HUGE HUGE PROBLEM.
AND WE WERE JUST REALLY.
.
SEEING SO MANY WELLS IN TANGLED
AYE I HAD.
A FEW YEARS AGO I HAD A BLUE
WELL THAT WAS ENTANGLED.
AND.
WE.
WHERE WE ARE UNABLE TO HELP IT?
AND.
THEWELL PROBABLY DIED AND
ANOTHER WELL THAT WAS ANOTHER
BLUE WELL THAT WAS ENTANGLED.
NOAH DIDN'T PUT IT TRACKING
BILLY ON.
AND THAT THEY HAD ONE BUT THEY
DIDN'T PUT IT ON THERE AND I
ARGUED WITH THEM ONE OF THEM TO
PUT IT ON. BUT THEY WOULDN'T PUT
IT ON AND WHY.
BECAUSE THEY WERE UNSURE OF
WHETHER THE WHALE WOULD GO OFF
TO SEE.
AND THIS BILL ANYWAYS FIFTY
POUNDS.
AND THE BULLY.
TEARS INTO THE FLESH OF THE
WELL SAID BECAUSE IT HUESO MUCH
SO I WORKED ON DESIGNING A NEW
BOOTY.
THAT ARE ONLY WEIGHS ELEVEN
POUNDS AND IT'S GREAT HOWEVER
WHAT THE GOVERNMENT?
OF THE UNITED STATES CAN'T MAKE
A BUOY THAT WEIGHS LESS THAN
FIFTY POUNDS.
I MEAN THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH EFFORT BEING
SPENT ON THESE ANIMALS.
TO HELP THEM AND WE NEED A WE
NEED MORE ATTENTION BEING PAID
TO THIS.
IF THEY WERE SEVENTY ONE WHAT OF
WHALES BEING COACHED BY POACHERS
RIGHT NOW.
HOW MUCH WOULD WE SPEND ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO STOP THAT?
NOT HOW MUCH ATTENTION WOULD BE
PAID TO IT. THIS IS A SERIOUS
PROBLEM AND IT'S TOTALLY
SOLVABLE.
THIS MAN RIGHT HERE.
HE HAS A BULLY I DON'T I DON'T
WORK FORM.
HE'S JUST ITS HIS OWN BUSINESS
BUT HE HAS A BUOY THAT HE'S BEEN
USING FOR YEARS.
IT WORKS THERE'S NO REASON THAT
ALL THE FISHERMEN IN THIS WHOLE
STATE COULDN'T BE USING THAT
BILLY. AND WE BASICALLY AND THE
PROBLEM.
BECAUSE MOST OF THE
ENTANGLEMENTS THEY'RE HAPPENING
OF CALIFORNIA MOST OF WHAT WE
SEE. IS FROM THESE.
THESE
BOWIE'S WITH ROPES SO IF YOU
HAVE NO ROPE AND NO BUOY YOU
HAVE NO PROBLEM.
AND SO WE'VE GOT TO GET SOME
MONEY.
.
YOU KNOW PUT TOWARDS THIS
PROBLEM.
AND THE AND WE NEED TO TO HAVE
REQUIRED THE FISHERMEN.
TO USE THESE BUOYS AND GIVEN
FIVE YEARS OR WHATEVER TIME YOU
THEY NEED TO GET EVERYTHING UP
AND RUNNING. AND THEN GIVE THEM
SOME HELP GIVING SOME SOME MONEY
TO PAY FOR THE BULLIES AND THE
PROBLEM SOLVED.
YOU KNOW WE'RE OUT THERE RISKING
OUR LIVES TRYING TO HELP WHALES
AND MOST THE TIME WE FAIL.
I MEAN I HAD TO MAKE A CHOICE
YESTERDAY GO SEE MY MOTHER IN
THE HOSPITAL WHO WHO'S DYING.
OR GO HELP WELL I WHAT I CHOSE
TO HELP THE WELL BECAUSE I WAS
THE ONLY ONE AVAILABLE TO DO IT.
AND WE FELT SO I MADE A BAD
CHOICE I'VE I WISH I WOULD'VE
GONE TO SEE MY MOM.
ANYWAY THANK YOU.
SO ONCE AGAIN MY NAME'S TOM
THAT'S HIM WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN CALIFORNIA I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
DUNGENESS CRAB.
FISHING YOU'RE WORKING GROUP
THAT WAS MENTIONED IN THE
EARLIER PRESENTATION.
I'VE BEEN A PART OF THAT GROUP
SINCE ITS INCEPTION IN
SEPTEMBER.
TWENTY FIFTEEN FOLLOWING THE
INCREASE IN THE OBSERVE
ENTANGLEMENTS OUT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
I WANT TO.
HIGHLIGHT THOUGH THAT THIS IS
IN FACT A GLOBAL ISSUE THE ON
AND NOT UNINTENTIONAL.
ENTANGLEMENT OF WHALES AROUND
THE WORLD IS ONE OF THE.
IF NOT THE.
TOP SOURCE OF HUMAN CAUSED
MORTALITY FOR WELL POPULATIONS
MANY OF WHICH AS YOU KNOW ARE
THREATENED AYE OR ENDANGERED.
NOW THIS WORKING GROUP.
HIS FOLKS WE HAD THREE TOP
GOALS.
UNDERSTANDING OF THE NATURE OF.
OF DRIVERS FOR ENTANGLEMENT
RISK REDUCING ENTANGLEMENT RISK
AND IN FACT THAT'S WHERE WE
SPENT MOST OF OUR TIME
ELIMINATING THIS PROBLEM BY
AVOIDING ENTITLEMENTS IN THE
FIRST PLACE. AND THEN AS AN
EARLIER SPEAKER SAID IMPROVING
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
RESPONSE WHEN.
WHALES ARE IN FACT.
ENTANGLED IN IN FISHING HERE SO
THOSE ARE THREE TOP GOALS I I
WILL SAY THAT THIS GROUP HAS
BEEN UNIQUE AND PRODUCTIVE IT'S
A MULTI STAKEHOLDER GROUPS OF
THE FEW FOLKS AROUND THE TABLE
IN ADDITION TO.
CONSERVATION GROUPS ARE.
COMMERCIAL RECREATIONAL
HARVESTERS STATE AND FEDERAL.
FISHERIES MANAGERS AS WELL AS.
WHERE RESEARCHERS AND AND?
WELL RESCUE.
REPRESENTATIVES AS WELL SO I
THINK IT ACTUALLY REPRESENTS A
REALLY VALUABLE MODEL FOR HOW.
CITY CALIFORNIA CAN.
COALESCING ADDRESSING.
AN URGENT CONSERVATION ISSUE
LIKE THIS.
WITHIN THE STATE.
THE INDUSTRY MEMBERS OF THAT
GROUP HAVE BEEN AT THE TABLE
FROM THE START AND AND REALLY
PRODUCTIVE AND PROACTIVE IN.
HELPING TO IDENTIFY.
NEW WAYS TO TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM.
THIS WORK HAS BEEN SUPPORTED BY
CALIFORNIA'S OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL ALONG WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. AND I JUST WANT TO
WALK THROUGH OUR PROGRESS IN THE
CHIEF AND ADVANCING THOSE THREE
GOALS.
SO IN TERMS OF UNDERSTANDING THE
DRIVERS OF THIS RISK EVERYONE
THAT YOU COULD SEE THAT.
THAT CHART THAT WAS.
PRESENTED EARLIER THE TABLE
WITH REGARD TO INCREASE IN
OBSERVED ENTANGLEMENTS.
AND IT IT JUMPS RIGHT OUT AT
YOU AND IT JUMPED OUT AT
BY THE FALL TWENTY FIFTEEN THAT
SOMETHING NEW WAS HAPPENING
HERE.
AND SOMETHING NEED TO BE DONE
ABOUT IT.
SO THE OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL
DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE
CONVENE A MEETING WHICH LAUNCHED
THIS WORKING GROUP.
SINCE THAT TIME THAT THAT GROUP
STARTED WITH HOW HOW WOULD WE
KNOW ABOUT THE DRIVERS FOR FOR
THAT PATTERN.
WHAT CAN WE LEARN AND WE REALLY
STARTED WITH INFORMATION
GATHERING AND COLLABORATIVE
RESEARCH TO UNDERSTAND?
WHAT WAS GOING ON IN TERMS THE
OCEAN YOU RECALL IT?
OVER THESE THREE YEARS ARE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN OCEAN
TEMPERATURES EL NINO EVENTS THE
WARM.
WATER BLAH THAT THAT SET OFF
THE COAST FOR SO LONG AND AND.
AND CHANGE SO MUCH IN OUR
OCEANS THAT ACTUALLY LEAD TO
CHANGES AND.
FOR IMPORTANTLY CREEL ANCHOVIES
AND SARDINES WITH CHEESE WELLS
ARE HERE TO FEED ON.
AND SO WE'RE ABLE TO SORT OF
UNDERSTAND WHAT THOSE OCEAN
CHANGES MEANT FOR FORAGE WITH
THOSE SPORTS CHANGES MEANT FOR
THE WHALES AND THEN GATHER MORE
INFORMATION ON WHAT WAS
HAPPENING. IN PARALLEL WITH THE
CHANGE IN THE DYNAMICS OF THE
CRAB FISHERY SEASONALITY
INTIMIDATION THE EFFORT.
OF THAT FLEET HAS CHANGED OVER
THESE YEARS AS WELL.
AS WE TRY TO REALLY GET AT.
WHAT WERE THE OVERLAP OR THE
INTERSECTIONS BETWEEN SOME OF
THOSE CHANGES THAT WE'RE SEEING
IN THE WATER AND IN THE FISHERY
AND WHAT?
A WHY DID THEY RESULT OR HOW DID
THEY CONTRIBUTE TO THAT THE
INCREASE IN OBSERVING TANG WHAT
THEY WERE SEEING.
I ONE OF THE LAST THINGS I WANT
CALL OUT IN THIS SECTION IS A WE
DID A LOT OF ANALYSIS OF THE
IMAGES AND SOME OF THE STORIES
IN THE DISENTANGLE AND EFFORTS.
LEARNING AS MUCH AS WE COULD
AND AND REALLY LEVERAGING THE
EXPERTISE THE HARVESTERS IN THE
ROOM.
TO BASICALLY DO FORENSIC
ANALYSIS OF WHAT WE COULD LEARN
ABOUT THE NATURE OF HOW I WHAT
FISHER WAS INVOLVED WHEN THAT
ATTAINMENT OCCURRED AND HOW THAT
WELL ACTUALLY INTERACTED WITH
THAT YOUR AND ENDED UP IN
ENTANGLED IN IT.
SO OUR NEXT GOAL WAS A REDUCING
THE RISK OF ENTANGLEMENT IN A
AFFORD FACING WHEN AND AS I SAID
THIS IS ON THE BULK OF OUR WORK.
EARLIER THEY MENTIONED THE.
SOMEONE MENTION THE BEST
PRACTICES GUIDE SO.
WHAT WE LEARNED FROM THAT
FORENSIC REVIEW OF OF IT PRIOR
ENTANGLEMENTS?
AND THE THE EXPERTISE OF.
SOME OF THE DISENTANGLE MEANT
RESPONDERS WAS THAT A LOT OF
THOSE INTERACTIONS WERE
HAPPENING AT THE SURFACE AT WHAT
IN THE THAT PART OF THAT CRAP.
SET UP THAT WE CALL THE TOP
HERE WHICH IS THE BUOYS AND
ROPES FLOATING I OFTEN AT THE
SURFACE.
THERE WAS A RECOGNITION THAT.
FOLKS COULD.
TIGHTEN UP HOW THEY WERE DOING
THAT AND THEY WERE SORT OF.
I NEED FOR ESTABLISHED BEST
PRACTICES AND TO REDUCE THE
PROFILE OF THAT AND THEREBY
REDUCE THE RISK THAT AN ANIMAL
GET ENTANGLED IN THAT YEAR. SO
WITH THAT INDUSTRY WE DEVELOPED.
WITH INDUSTRY PARTNERS ABOUT
THAT BEST PRACTICES GUIDE IN
HAVE CIRCULATED THAT THROUGHOUT
THE FISHERY.
AND A LOT OF THOSE QUALITIES
VOLUNTARY LOT OF.
THOSE PRACTICES HAVE.
HAVE INCREASED UP AND DOWN THE
COAST THE NEXT THING WE FOCUSED
ON IS LOST YOUR INITIATIVES SO
THE END OF THE SEASON WOULDN'T
SOMEONE MENTIONED A LOT HERE SO
I'D YEARS UNINTENTIONALLY LAS
SOMETIMES IT'S. DRAGGED UP BY
ANOTHER BOAT OR TUGBOAT ARE
MOVED BY STORM ARE STUCK.
SO WE'VE GOT SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED OUR INVESTMENTS.
IN ENSURING THAT ALL THAT
YOU'RE.
COMES OUT OF THE WATER AT THE
END OF THE SEASON IT DOESN'T
CONTINUE TO REPRESENT A RISK OF
OF ENTITLEMENT MOVING FORWARD.
AND WE'RE INVESTING IN TOOLS.
AND PORTRAIT APPROACH JUST HELP
EXPEDITE AND IMPROVE THE SCALING
OF OF THOSE EFFORTS AND THAT
WORK IS ONGOING.
.
ALSO.
THIS GROUP HAS RECOMMENDED A
UNIFORM YOU'RE MARKING AND THIS
IS PART OF UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE NATURE THESE ENTANGLEMENTS.
THE CRAB FISHERY IS ONE PART OF
THIS PROBLEM BUT IT'S CERTAINLY
NOT THE ONLY FISH IN CALIFORNIA
THAT HAS.
CAUSED ENTANGLEMENTS NAM OR
ALONG THE WEST COAST FOR THAT
MATTER SO DIE UNIFORM.
FISHING GEAR MARKING WOULD GO A
LONG WAY TO HELPING US
UNDERSTAND BUT WE DO HAVE AN
ENTANGLEMENT.
WHAT WHAT WE CAN LEARN FROM
THAT IN ORDER TO PREVENT A
FUTURE ENTANGLEMENT SO THAT'S
ACTUALLY ARE CURRENTLY IN A
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL I SP
THIRTEEN OH NINE WHICH IS MAKING
ITS WAY THROUGH THE PROCESS
RIGHT NOW?
ONE OF THE.
MOST PRODUCTIVE I THINK WHAT
MOST.
.
POTENTIALLY A HIGHEST IMPACT.
AREAS OF OUR FOCUS HAS BEEN IN
AN EARLY WARNING SYSTEM.
AND THIS IS TAKING ALL THOSE
FACTORS THAT WE LEARNED WHAT'S
CHANGING IN THE OCEAN WHAT'S
CHANGING IN THE FORGE WHAT THE
WHALES DOING WITH THE FISHERY
DOING. AND CREATING BATES GOING
EARLY WARNING SYSTEM A
CHARACTERIZATION OF THE OF THE
YEAR SPECIFIC RISK WHAT WE KNOW
BASED ON THOSE FACTORS WE GET
SAY OKAY THIS IS THAT A
BASICALLY A NORMAL YEAR. OR WE
HAVE SOME MODERATE MODERATELY
ELEVATED RISK WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANTLY ELEVATED RISK I'M
WE NEED TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
MITIGATING STEPS SO WE'RE
DEVELOPING THIS FIRST OF ITS
KIND.
ADAPTIVE RISK MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
CHARACTERIZE RISK AHEAD OF THE
SEASON AND DURING THE SEASON
AND.
THROUGH THIS MULTI STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS RECOMMEND TO.
IMMEDIATE MITIGATING STEPS NONE
MOVING FORWARD SO WERE PILOTING
THAT NOW WE'VE LEARNED A TON
ABOUT THAT AND ON THAT THE MODEL
THEY THINK HAS REAL POTENTIAL TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
ACROSS FISHERIES IN CALIFORNIA
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I'M WE ARE SUPPORTING THE
WORKING GROUP IS POINTING AT
ONGOING RESEARCH INTO A NUMBER
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF YOUR
INNOVATION REDUCING THE LINE
PROFILE USING BREAKAWAYS. I AND
OTHERS SOME WORK IN.
THE WE LIST OR ACOUSTIC RELEASE
TRAPS AT WORK HAVE BEEN TALKED
ABOUT HERE. I THINK THAT IS VERY
PROMISING WORK ON IT THAT AN
EXPERIMENTAL PHASE I THINK.
WE'RE.
VERY INTERESTED IN AND
EXPLORING THE MECHANICS THE
OPERATIONS THE COSTS TO THE THE
DOWNSIDE OF OF MOVING FORWARD IN
THAT DIRECTION BUT I DO THINK IT
IS PROMISING.
THE FINAL THING I AM IS
IMPROVING THE RESPONSE WE'VE
MADE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
BUILDING THE HUMAN CAPACITY OF
ART THE CONTAINMENT NETWORK.
WE'VE DONE HUNDRED AND WE'VE
DONE SEVERAL TRAININGS RESULTING
IN ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY TO TWO
HUNDRED A NEW FIRST RESPONDERS
THESE ARE MOSTLY COMMERCIAL AND
RECREATIONAL FISHERMEN. WHO
SPEND SO MUCH TIME ON THE WATER
TRYING TO LEVERAGE THEIR
EXPERTISE AND?
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO PLAY A KEY
ROLE IN OBSERVING ENTANGLED
ANIMALS IDENTIFYING THAT AND AN
INITIATING THAT THE RESPONSE
THAT ON THE PRIOR SPEAKER
MENTIONED.
BUT WE ARE ALSO INVESTING IN
IMPROVED AND REDESIGNED TOOLS TO
HELP FACILITATE MORE EFFECTIVE
ENTANGLEMENT.
AND SAY CONTENTMENT ON THE
WATER.
SO IN CLOSING.
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY WORKING TO
ADDRESS THIS CRITICAL THREAT TO
TO WALES ON CALIFORNIA'S COAST
THAT WORK IS ONGOING.
IT IS.
FAR FROM DONE THERE'S THERE'S
STILL PLANNING TO DO.
AND YET THE RESULTS OF OUR WORK
IS ALREADY BEING SHARED AROUND
THE COUNTRY FOR OTHER REGIONS
OTHER FISHERIES FACING SIMILAR
CHALLENGES AND I'M SURE MANY OF
YOU HEARD WHAT'S.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN IN NEW
ENGLAND AS WELL SO CALIFORNIA'S
FAR FROM ALONE IN IN.
TRYING TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO
THESE PROBLEMS.
I AND THERE CONTINUES TO BE A
REAL NEED TO INVEST IN
EXPERIMENTATION AND NEW
SOLUTIONS.
AND COLLABORATIVE RESEARCH AND
LOOK FOR DEBT TO WORKING WITH
YOUR COMMITTEE WITH THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL THE
DEPARTMENT FISH WILDLIFE AND AND
SO MANY OTHERS TO TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT. THAT WORK GETS DONE.
IT'S GREAT THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR PRESENTATIONS.
I'VE IF THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
FROM THE DIET SO WILL THAT ASK
OF FATHER ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO BE HEARD ON
THIS ISSUE.
SITE INFORMATION ONLY BUT WE DO
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING CUT NO ONE I WILL.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR WHAT WE DO.
YOU SO MUCH FOR I'M HAVING THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT PRESENTATION.
LEAH.
INCREDIBLE TEAM ACTUALLY BEEN
OUT ON.
WELL SAFARI WITH.
WITH YOUR AMAZING ORGANIZATION
WE'VE BEEN ON A COUPLE OF
SAFARIS THROUGH WORLD ANIMAL
NEWS IS WHILE WE FILMS FOR.
MY CHARITY PIECE FOR ANIMALS.
AND ON THIS IS A BIG ISSUE.
.
I'VE SEEN A PLENTY WHALES. OFF
THE COAST OF CALIFORNIA AND
TANGLED.
IN THESE IN THESE FISHING NETS
AND ALSO.
YOU KNOW THE ONES THAT THEY
DROPPED TWO HUNDRED FEET DOWN IN
THE OCEAN AND THEY KEEP IN THEIR
FOR TWELVE HOURS AND.
UNFORTUNATELY.
YOU KNOW. THERE'S SO MUCH BI
CATCH THE GETS CAUGHT THAT
REALLY THERE'S NO ACCURATE COUNT
SO.
WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE THE
FIGURES YOU KNOW I THINK IT WAS
FROM TWO THOUSAND AND ONE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THERE WAS
LITERALLY. I THINK FIFTEEN
HUNDRED ANIMALS THAT THEY
ACTUALLY COUNTED.
OF WHICH YOU KNOW HOW CAN YOU
REALLY. GUESSTIMATE THAT
IF YOU CAN'T I MEAN WITH THE
AMOUNT OF FISHING LINE RUNNING
MILES AND MILES AND MILES AND
THE OCEAN. THERE'S REALLY NO
ACCURATE WAY TO DO THAT SO.
YOU KNOW MY QUESTION IS THAT
YOU KNOW WHY ISN'T THERE.
MORE FUNDING. PUT TOWARDS THIS
WHY.
YOU KNOW THESE ANIMALS ARE SOME
OF THEM ARE ON THE BRINK OF
EXTINCTION.
.
IF WE LOSE THESE ANIMALS WHAT
WILL THE IMPACT SPEED A
CALIFORNIA NOT ONLY JUST
CALIFORNIA BUT THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
YOU KNOW.
IS MONEY AND GREED REALLY THAT
IMPORTANT.
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO IT.
WE HAVE TO PLACE MORE VALUE ON
LIFE. AND I THINK THAT GOES WITH
ALL ENDANGERED SPECIES ALL
ANIMALS WE SHARE THIS PLANET
WITH EIGHT POINT SEVEN MILLION
SPECIES OF WHICH.
WE ONLY KNOW ABOUT THE REST UP
TO A HUNDRED MILLION THAT ARE IN
THE RAINFOREST OF WHICH WERE
CUTTING DOWN AT AN ALARMING
RATE.
GETS EVERY.
TWO FOOTBALL FIELDS EVERY HALF
AN HOUR.
FOR SOMETHING CALLED PALM OIL.
AND OF COURSE LOGGING IS
ANOTHER ISSUE BUT.
THAT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT
BALLGAME.
THE AMOUNT THAT WE'RE PUTTING.
ON THE VALUE.
OF.
SOMETHING THAT.
WELL NOT OUTLIVE US.
DOESN'T COMPARE TO THE VALUE
THAT WE CAN PUT ON SOMETHING
THAT WILL OUTLIVE US.
WHICH IS LIFE.
SO.
WE LEAVE WITH COMPASSION I
UNDERSTAND THAT.
.
BEING HERE IT'S IT'S A LOT OF
FIVE FIGURES AND NUMBERS AND.
THIS RIGHT THING TO DO IN THIS
IS BUSINESS.
WELL. YOU CAN'T TAKE BUSINESS
WITH YOU WHEN YOU DIE.
BUT YOU CAN LEAVE A LASTING
IMPRESSION.
ON THIS PLANET AND THE REST OF
THIS PLANET'S SPECIES AND IT'S
NOT JUST FOR US IT'S NOT JUST
FOR HUMANS.
BECAUSE THIS IS JUST WORK
RELEASING THIS LAND.
THIS IS JUST THIS IS A GIFT AND
IF WE CAN'T TAKE CARE OF THIS
GIFT THIS IS OUR ONLY PLANET.
TAKE CARE OF THIS PLANET BEFORE
WE GO TO VISIT OTHER PLANETS.
SO.
.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
HA THIS IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO SEE A
PLANET WITHOUT THE SPECIES.
AND I REFUSE TO SEE A PLAN
WITHOUT THE SPECIES AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE FIGHTING SO HARD.
TO PROTECT THEM STEP.
THANK YOU FOR THAT BIT OF
INSPIRATION AND IT CAN I SHARE
JUST ONE THING REAL QUICK.
WE DO HAVE TO WRAP UP BUT JEFF
YOU CAN DO IT FOR EQUITY ARE
HIGH WHAT I WANTED TO SAY IS
THAT I KNOW THAT THE FISHERMEN
CARE ABOUT THESE ANIMALS AND
THEY DON'T WANT TO CATCH THEM.
AND I KNOW THAT ALL THESE PEOPLE
IN THIS ROOM CARE I THINK
EVERYBODY WANTS TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS.
THAT NO ONE CAN DECIDE ON HOW TO
DO IT. AND I THINK THAT.
WHAT WE NEED IS A SOLUTION THAT
WE KNOW WORKS AND? HONESTLY THIS
GUY HAS ONE THAT REALLY WORKS
IT'S IT ALREADY IS IN PRACTICE
IT'S BEING USED.
IT'S NOT A PROTOTYPE IT'S A
WORKING.
IT'S BEING SOLD IT'S BEEN SO IT
THE MILITARY IS THAT.
AND ALL WE HAVE TO DO IS GET THE
PRICE DOWN WHICH CAN EASILY BE
DONE IF WE MASS PRODUCE IT AND
THIS COULD BE USED THIS
TECHNOLOGY WILL WORK ANYWAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU I CERTAINLY
AGREE WITH YOU I THINK I
EVERYONE IS ON THE SAME PAGE
THAT OF. THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
AND I APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU
HELPING A SHUTTLE LITTLE A
ADDITIONAL LIGHT ON WHAT I THINK
IS.
AYE EVERYONE WHO KNOWS ABOUT IT
FEELS IT'S IMPORTANT BUT NOT
THAT MANY PEOPLE KNOW SO NOW FEW
MORE DO AND. WILL KEEP ON MOVING
FORWARD. AND ARGUE ALL THINGS
RICHARD THANKS FOR HAVING.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE FIVE TWO I
ISSUE TO.
THROUGH FIVE THAT'S DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS AND RECREATION.
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
GOOD MORNING WILL.
WELL WE'RE GETTING SITUATED TO.
LET ME JUST ANNOUNCED IT WILL
TAKE ISSUES TWO THROUGH FIVE.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FOR PARKS
AND RECREATION ASKED THEM TO
JUST MOVE.
THROUGH OUR EACH OF THOSE ISSUES
AND THEN WE'LL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THAT DEPARTMENT.
WHEN ISSUE FIVE AFTER SHE FIVE
IT'S BEEN.
ADDRESSED.
MY MISTER CHAIRMAN ON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU FOR HAVING US
HERE AND WE SMOG AND THE
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION.
I'M IN BEFORE WE DISCUSS OUR
INDIVIDUAL BUDGET REQUESTS OF
LIKE TO GIVE YOU REALLY A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE EFFORTS HAD BEEN
UNDERWAY BLOOM AT THE
DEPARTMENT.
THE PARKS BOARD COMMISSION IT
WAS A BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED.
TO DO A TOP DOWN REVIEW OF IRAQ
OF OUR ORGANIZATION AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW STRENGTH
IN THE DEPARTMENT. AND THE STATE
PARK SYSTEM IT RELEASED ITS
FINAL RECOMMENDATIONS IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN. THE
ADMINISTRATION THEN IN TURN TO
STAB LIST.
FATIMA PARK EXPERTS THAT WAS
DUBBED THE TRANSFORMATION TEAM
TO DESIGN VERY SPECIFIC
ACTIONABLE INITIATIVES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS WAS NOT A REPORT.
THAT NEARLY GATHER DUST ON ON A
SHELF SOMEWHERE.
AND SO WITH YOUR HELP WE'VE
ACCOMPLISHED A LOT OF LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT SOME OF OUR MORE
NOTABLE COLLECTIVE ACHIEVEMENTS.
AND FIRST I WOULD SAY THAT WE'RE
MODERNIZING HOW WE ARE
ORGANIZED.
INFORMED BY PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT
PROCESS WE'VE DESIGNED AN
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE
ELIMINATING REDUNDANT
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES WHILE
ENHANCING KEY VISITORS SERVICE
PROGRAMS ARE PLAN IS
MEMORIALIZED IN OUR OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN REPORT.
WE'VE ALSO DIVERSIFIED OUR
LEADERSHIP TEAM.
REQUIREMENT THAT OUR TOP LEADERS
IN THE FIELD BE LIMITED TO ONE
PROFESSIONAL GROUP HAS BEEN
ELIMINATED.
PART PROBLEMS ARE BEST SOLVED BY
A TEAM WHICH IS WITH THAT WHICH
INCLUDES INDIVIDUALS FROM A
BROAD. RANGE OF PROFESSIONAL
BACKGROUNDS AND OUR LEADERSHIP
TEAM IS NOW ABLE TO REFLECT THAT
SAME PROFESSIONAL DIVERSITY.
WE MODERNIZE FEE COLLECTION
THEIR TECHNOLOGY DEBIT AND
CREDIT CARDS NOW ACCEPTED AT
MORE AND MORE OF CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS.
WE'VE MODERNIZE HOW WE TAKE
RESERVATIONS HOW WE COLLECT DATA
AND REVENUE AND MANAGE THE
CAMPING RESERVATION INVENTORY
FOR THE PUBLIC. THE NEW DATA
ALLOWS FORM MORE A MATTER
INFORMED BUSINESS DECISIONS
ACROSS THE DEPARTMENT WHILE ALSO
HELPING US IMPROVE OUR VISITORS
EXPERIENCES.
WE'RE HARNESSING THE POWER OF
PHILANTHROPY AND PARTNERSHIPS.
WE'VE CREATED MORE DIRECT LINES
OF COMMUNICATIONS
BETWEEN OUR KEY VERY IMPORTANT
PARTNERS.
THE FIELD AND THE LEADERSHIP
TEAM BY CREATING A TEAM FOCUSED
ON FACILITATING AND SUPPORTING
PROGRAM ENHANCEMENT PARTNERSHIPS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE PARK
SYSTEM.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS ALSO HOSTED A
SUMMIT WITH OVER ONE HUNDRED OF
OUR PARTNERS INCLUDING VOLUNTEER
ORGANIZATIONS NONPROFIT
FOUNDATIONS AND OTHER
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES AND
RECOGNITION OF THE IMPORTANT
ROLE THAT THEY PLAY IN THE
FUTURE OF OUR STATE PARK
DEPARTMENT IN THE SYSTEM.
AND WE'VE ALSO IMPROVE PRIORITY
SETTING AND WE'VE INCREASED
ACCOUNTABILITY.
IN THE PAST.
ARE FUNDS WERE DISTRIBUTED TO
THE TWENTY ONE MANAGEMENT UNITS
TO BE SPENT AT THE DISCRETION OF
FIELDS MANAGEMENT.
NOW THROUGH THE USE OF A NEW
BUDGET TOOL PRIORITY BASED
BUDGETING IS NOW THE NEW NORM.
WHILE STILL ALLOWING PARK STAFF
TO DETERMINE HOW TO BEST
ACCOMPLISH
THE GOALS.
THAT WE'VE ESTABLISHED FOR THE
DEPARTMENT.
TODAY WILL BE PROVIDING YOU AN
OVERVIEW.
YOU SEE IT UP ON YOUR.
MONITOR THEIR.
WILL BE PROVIDING YOU AN
OVERVIEW OF THIS NEW BUDGET TOLD
WHICH WE'VE JUST.
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING.
AND I MUST SAY A IT IS PROVED
TO BE A VERY POWERFUL TOOL.
IT'S HELPED US DETERMINE HOW TO
BEST ALLOCATE THE RESOURCES THAT
WE HAVE AND IT'S ALSO HELPED US
MORE MEANINGFUL WAY WHICH IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT. ARMED
WITH OUR PARTNERS AND
PHILANTHROPIC GROUPS AND ALSO
WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF.
ON THIS PROJECT THE SERVICE
BASED BUDGETING PROJECT THIS
POWERFUL TOOL IS MADE POSSIBLE
THROUGH PHILANTHROPIC SUPPORT.
AND.
QUITE CANDIDLY JUST THE SHEER
HARD WORK ON OF THE DEDICATED
PART STUFF THAT RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANT ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS TOOL.
I LIKE TO CLOSE BY THINKING THE
LEGISLATURE THINKING YOU'RE STOP
THINKING WHICH STAKEHOLDERS.
.
FOR WORKING ALONGSIDE US TO MAKE
THE SYSTEM OUT SYSTEMATIC
CHANGES.
THE TYPES OF CHANGES AND
IMPROVEMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
IN PLACE WITH BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE PARK SYSTEM.
ON IN THE PITS AND THE COUNTLESS
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT SESSIONS THAT
WE'VE HAD I THINK IS A TESTAMENT
TO. SOME KIND OF SOMETHING THAT
CAN ONLY HAPPEN THAT THIS KIND
OF CHANGE COULD NOT HAPPEN JUST
INTERNALLY NAM THAT IT REALLY
WAS KIND OF ONE OF OUR KEY WAYS
WE'VE DEMONSTRATED THAT. THE
POWER OF PARTNERSHIP AN EXTERNAL
ENGAGEMENT.
AND SO WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR WE CAN
MOVE TO THE PRESENTATION. THANK
YOU ALL JUST TO ADD A COMMENT
AND MR FUNG MAY HAVE A QUESTION
OR COMMENT AS WELL.
OR NOT. HAVE TO.
WHEN I ARRIVE TO AND WE BEGAN
HOLDING HEARINGS AND AND.
TWENTY THIRTEEN.
HI YOUR DEPARTMENT WAS FRONT AND
CENTER.
AND MANY OF THE ISSUES.
THAT EXISTED.
WERE.
ON THE. DOCKET TO TO TO BE
ADDRESSED AND I FRANKLY THE
DEPARTMENT WAS WASN'T A MASS.
SINCE THAT TIME.
IN THE RELATIVELY SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME.
A THINGS HAVE REALLY TURNED
AROUND.
ADD TO IT A.
JUST WANT TO CONGRATULATE YOU ON
THE WORK THAT TO YOU IN THE MEN
AND WOMEN OF.
YOUR DEPARTMENT HAVE DONE TO
MAKE THOSE CHANGES A REALITY I
THINK THAT THE. PUBLIC GOTTA.
.
EXPERIENCES THE.
AT A MUCH.
BETTER. OUT OVERALL PARKS
EXPERIENCE TODAY THAN THEY DID
TO THOSE FEW SHORT YEARS AGO.
AND THAT'S TESTAMENT TO THE HARD
WORK OF THE PEOPLE IN YOUR
DEPARTMENT SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
PLEASE PROCEED WITH FAILURE
ADDITIONAL ITEMS ON REMIND DE
EVER WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT.
AFTER YOU'VE CONCLUDED ON ISSUE
FIVE.
SO GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS WILL
SHOPS BY I AM THAT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES FOR STATE PARKS.
AND JUST A QUICK OVERVIEW OF
SERVER SPACE BUDGETING.
SO SIR SPACE BUDGET OR S. B. B.
I ROSE FROM. ONE OF STATE PARKS
TRANSFORMATION TEAM STRATEGIC
GOALS WHICH WAS DEVELOPED TO
DEVELOPMENT EXCELLENT MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS.
TO MEET THAT OBJECTIVE STATE
PARKS EMBARKED ON A ROBUST DATA
COLLECTION AND ANALYSIS EFFORT
LABELED SERVER SPACE BUDGET AND.
THIS PROJECT ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT ANALYZE SERVICE
LEVELS ACROSS ITS NUMEROUS
PROGRAMS TO BETTER INFORM FISCAL
DECISION MAKING PROCESSES.
RESPOND TO THE NEEDS OF OUR
VISITORS AND COMMUNICATE WITH
OUR PARTNERS.
WHAT WE HAVE IN PLACE NOW IS A
HYBRID BUDGET AND SYSTEM THAT
COMBINES THE BEST ASPECTS OF?
ZERO BASED BUDGETING AND
PERFORMANCE BASED BUDGETING.
SO WHAT IS SERVICE BUT IN.
SERVICE SPACE BUDGETING TAKES
ZERO BASED BUDGETING APPROACH
AND THAT IT DOCUMENTS ALL
SERVICES NEEDED THROUGHOUT THE
DEPARTMENT.
TO ACHIEVE ITS MISSION AND WE
DEFINE THIS AS THE MISSION LEVEL
IN THE DATA SET.
THE SERVICES ARE THEN
CHARACTERIZED BY PROGRAM SUCH AS
FACILITIES OR VISITOR SERVICES.
AND STDS SERVICES ARE COMPILED
BY DOCUMENTING SMALLER LABOR
TASKS A GIVEN PARK FOR EXAMPLE
CHECKING A VISITOR AND AT THE
NEW BRIGHTON STATE BEACH
CAMPGROUND.
THAT TASK WOULD THEN BE ASSIGNED
HOURS COST PASSED DRIVERS SUCH
AS NUMBER OF EXPECTED VISITORS.
JUSTIFICATION GLOBAL STANDARDS.
SUCH AS WE WANT TO GET TO TWO
MINUTES PROJECT AND.
AND WE WOULD THEN ASSIGN LABOR
CLASSIFICATIONS IN THE ASSOCIATE
OPERATING EQUIPMENT AND
EXPENSES.
AND THAT'S KIND OF THE
PERFORMANCE SPACE BUDGET ASPECT
OF SERVER SPACE BUT YOU MAY.
SO ANNUALLY WE WILL DETERMINE
HOW MUCH TIME WE INVEST IN EACH
SERVICE AND HOW MUCH MONEY WE
SPEND ANY SERVICE AND WHETHER OR
NOT WE ARE MEETING OUR
DELIVERABLES.
WE ARE CURRENTLY TRANSITION
INTO AN ELECTRONIC TIME KEEPING
SYSTEM. WHICH WILL HELP US TRACK
THIS IN A MORE AUTOMATIC FORMAT.
AND ANNUALLY WOULD REFRESHED.
THIS CURRENT SERVICE LEVEL SO
WILL ALWAYS HAVE A FRESH DATA
SAID TO ANALYZE WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT'S NEEDS ARE.
THE DOCUMENTATION OF S. B. B.
TASKS AND SERVICES WAS VERY
ROBUST THE MISSION LEVEL DATA
COLLECTION EFFORT SPANS ALL
ASPECTS OF THE DEPARTMENT AND
CAPTURES EVERY TASK THAT A STATE
PARK EMPLOYEE. VOLUNTEER OR
PARTNER COULD UNDERTAKE.
TO ACHIEVE THIS STATE PARKS
UNLISTED THIRTY THREE FIELD.
AND HEADQUARTERS SUBJECT MATTER
ASK SPURTS
AND HELD SEVEN STATEWIDE
TRANSACTIONS
AND ALL OVER FOR HIM IN STATE
PARKS EMPLOYEES PARTICIPATE IN
THE DATA GATHERING PROCESS.
THIS IS BY FAR THE MOST
DIFFICULT AND TIME CONSUMING
PHASE OF THE PROJECT.
WE DOCUMENTED A TOTAL OF OVER
ONE HUNDRED AND FOUR THOUSAND
UNIQUE TASKS WITHIN STATE PARKS
EACH OF THOSE TASKS HAS BEEN
ASSIGNED A COST AND IS AND EACH
A SCALABLE.
AND WHAT I MEAN BY SKILL WAS
THAT WE HAVE INCLUDED VARIABLES
THAT CAN CHANGE THE COST IF WE
INCREASE OR DECREASE FOR
EXAMPLE.
FACILITY PROJECTS OR VISITATION
TO A PARK.
WE HAVE ALSO DETERMINE WHICH OF
THOSE TASKS AND SERVICES ARE
CURRENTLY PROVIDED WHICH ONES
ARE NOT AND TO WHAT EXTENT.
SO.
THE IMPACTS AND OUTCOMES OF S.
B. BEER ILLUSTRATE ON THE SLIDE
IN AND AS THE DIRECTOR MENTIONED
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO HERE IS
ENABLE THE DEPARTMENT TO PRESENT
A CLEAR AND REALISTIC PICTURE.
OF OPERATIONS IN BUDGET
MANAGEMENT.
PROMOTE A CULTURE TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY ACROSS DPR
BOTH TO THE PUBLIC AND WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT.
ENABLE THE DEPARTMENT TO BUILD
FISCAL INTEGRITY AND TRUST AND
FACILITATE DATA DRIVEN DECISION
MAKING FOR ALLOCATION PURPOSE.
WITH SPV DATA WE ARE ABLE TO
CONSTRUCT MANAGEMENT DASHBOARDS
AND ANALYTICS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT.
THE DOW SPORTS WILL NOT ONLY BE
USED BY BOTH EXECUTIVE
MANAGEMENT.
FOR RESOURCE ALLOCATION
PERFORMANCE MEASUREMENT PURPOSES
BUT ALSO BY THE VARIOUS DISTRICT
OFFICES THROUGHOUT THE
DEPARTMENT.
FOR DATA DAY OPERATIONAL
PLANNING AND RESOURCE DEPLOYMENT
PURPOSES.
THE DA'S FORTY SEE HERE DISPLAY
SEVERAL FUNCTIONS OF SBB DATA
SET.
AND I KNOW IT MAY BE HARD FOR
SOME FOLKS TO SEE THE SUNAND
THE BACK HERE SO THIS KIND OF.
ILLUSTRATE WHAT WHAT THESE
DIFFERENT ASPECTS ARE.
THE UPPER LEFT HAND CORNER
MEASURES THE DISTRICTS CURRENT
SERVICE LEVEL NOT SHOWN THE TEAL
BLUE.
AGAINST ALL SERVICES OR VARIANTS
WHICH WOULD BE THE BLACK.
THE RED SHOWS THE AVERAGE
SERVICE LEVEL ACROSS THIS
DISTRICTS.
THE FUEL GAUGE LOOKING GRAPH
BELOW THAT SHOWS OUR CURRENT
SERVICE LEVEL AGAINST MISSION
LEVELIN TERMS OF DOLLARS OR P.
WISE.
SO WE KNOW WHAT WE HAVE AND WHAT
THE NEED IS AND CAN USE THAT
INFORMATION TO BETTER ALLOCATE
OUR RESOURCES.
ON THE RIGHT.
WE WE SHOW.
INDIVIDUAL PARKING AT VARIANCE
IN TERMS RELATIVE TO OTHER PARTS
AND DISTRICTS.
IN OTHER WORDS WHICH PARKS THE
MORE RESOURCE ALLOCATION THAN
OTHERS.
DEPICTED BY REDS OR GREEN SO THE
RATS WOULD NEED MORE RESOURCE
ALLOCATION THE GREENS WOULD BE
LESS.
SO AS WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING S.
B. B. CAN BE USED FOR A VARIETY
OF PURPOSES INCLUDING A RESOURCE
ALLOCATION.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
FORTY TWO MILLION TO ADDRESS
STATE PARK SERVICE LEVELS. AND
MATTER CONSISTENT WITH OUR STATE
PARKS REORGANIZATION.
FOR THE FIRST TIME STATE PARKS
WAS ABLE TO LOOK AT EXISTING
SERVICE LEVELS THROUGHOUT EVERY
LEVEL OF THE ORGANIZATION.
DETERMINE WHERE BEST TO ALLOCATE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS.
THE CHART ABOVE DISPLAYS
ALLOCATION OF FORTY TWO MILLION
OF STATE PARKS AND RECREATION
FUND BY PROGRAM.
IN THE PAST WE COULD ONLY MAKE
THIS PRESENTATION AT A DISTRICT
LEVEL AND RECENTLY A PARKING AT
LEVEL THROUGH AN EFFORT CALLED
PARK IN IT COSTING.
HOWEVER NEITHER OF THOSE EFFORTS
TO SPEAK TO PROGRAM OR SERVICE
AND A USEFUL MANNER.
THE HOPE HERE IS THAT THROUGHOUT
THROUGH THIS EFFORT WE CAN HAVE
MORE INFORMED CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT WHAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
DOING WITH THE APPROPRIATIONS IT
RECEIVES FROM THE LEGISLATURE.
AND MAKE INCREASINGLY BETTER
DECISIONS WITH THOSE FUNDS GOING
FORWARD.
AND THEN OUR POLY RAN SHORT ON
TIME SO LET US RECAP THAT. THE
BENEFITS OF S. B. B. AGAIN.
.
SO WE'VE GOT BETTER
COMMUNICATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ADMINISTRATION AND
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE AS WELFARE
STATE PARK PARTNERS ARE VISITORS
AND THE PUBLIC.
WE HAVE INCREASED UNDERSTAND OF
WHICH STATE PARKS PROGRAMS ARE
FLOURISHING AND WHICH ONES NEED
ADDITIONAL ALLOCATION.
COST TRANSPARENCY FOR THE
SERVICES WE PROVIDE MEANING HOW
MUCH DOES IT TAKE TO RUN A
CAMPFIRE PROGRAM AT CALAVERAS
VICTORIES FOR EXAMPLE.
WE HAVE DATA DRIVEN DECISION
MAKING THROUGH THE USE OF
ANALYTICS.
REPORTING FLEXIBILITY.
MY UNDERTAKEN THE LARGE DATA
COLLECTION EFFORT WE CAN PIVOT
THE DATA TO RESPOND TO MANY
DIFFERENT TYPES OF REQUESTS FOR
DATA.
AND INFORMATION CONSISTENCY SO
WE HAVE ONE PLATFORM THAT NOW
ALLOWS THE DIFFERENT CORNERS OF
THE DEPARTMENT TO SPEAK THE SAME
LANGUAGE.
AND THE LONGER TERM.
THE CONTINUED USE OF THE DATA
SET AND REFRESH NOT DOUBTS THAT
WILL ALLOW THE BERMAN TO LINE
WITH THE LONG TERM. GOALS OF THE
STATE. WILL BE ABLE TO MORE
EFFICIENTLY.
DO BUSINESS AS.
BEST PRACTICES ARE REVEALED IN
SHARED WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
S. B. B. WILL BE USED TO
EVALUATE DEPARTMENTAL
PERFORMANCE ON MULTIPLE LEVELS
INCLUDING AT THE DISTRICT
HEADQUARTERS LEVELS.
AND WE HOPE TO BEGIN FEE IN
EXPENDITURE DATA TIME KEEPING
DATA INTO THE SYSTEM ONCE WE ARE
FULLY IMPLEMENTED WITH OTHER
MODERNIZATION.
SYSTEMS AND EFFORTS SUCH AS
FISCAL AND ELECTRONIC TIME
KEEPING.
THAT WRAPS UP IN.
I'LL TAKE ANY QUESTIONS IF THERE
ARE ANY THANK YOU AYE I'LL JUST
SAY THAT.
AT AND I THINK OF THE.
INFORMATION.
THAT YEAR.
ABLE TO UTILIZE IN YOUR
DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
IS REALLY ENHANCED BY THE.
.
A SOFTWARE TOOL THAT THAT THAT
THAT YOU HAVE AND. I COULD SEE
WHERE THAT MIGHT HAVE
APPLICABILITY IN OTHER
DEPARTMENTS
A AS AS WELL SEE REALLY IN THE
IN THE VANGUARD HERE I THINK A.
LOT ON THAT IT'S VERY
IMPRESSIVE.
WE'RE GONNA PAUSE FOR ONE MINUTE
WELL I HAVE FOR THE TWO CAPTIVE
MEMBERS HERE AND. A ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
HELLO HERE.
FONG HERE KALRA MULLIN
PATTERSON.
THE BRITISH WERE OFFICIAL THANK
YOU.
.
WOULD LIKE TO PROCEED TO THE
NEXT STEP PARTICULAR.
PRESENTATION.
SURE I'M WITH THIS WILL MOVE TO
THE INDIVIDUAL BUDGET REQUEST
THAT WE HAVE BEFORE YOU.
YOUR FIRST.
ITEM FOR OUR DEPARTMENT IS ON
PAGE THIRTY ISSUE TO. ARM THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING ONGOING
FUNDING AND NEW POSITIONS ARE
FORTY TWO MILLION. OR ONGOING
FUNDING OF SIXTY ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION AND THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FOUR FULL TIME POSITIONS THIS
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE IS
INFORMED BY BOTH FAR UMP ATTIRE
ORGANIZATIONAL NAM THE
MODERNIZATION ORGANIZATION. A
PROJECT THAT WE.
ARE LAUNCHING AND ALSO ALONG
WITH THE SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
TOOL THAT WE JUST PRESENTED TO
YOU MORE SPECIFICALLY I'D LIKE
TO WALK THROUGH WHAT THAT SIXTY
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION IS
COMPRISED OF. FORTY TWO MILLION
OF THAT IS SPECIFICALLY FOR
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR
POSITIONS ON I THINK A COUPLE OF
REALLY KEY THINGS FOR US TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY WHOSE POSITIONS NINETY
PERCENT OF THOSE POSITIONS. ARE
OUT IN THE FIELDS ON THAT WAS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY
WHERE WE CAN MUST DIRECTLY
IMPACT THE VISITOR'S EXPERIENCE.
AND ALSO VAST MAJORITY OF THEM
ARE RANK AND FILE ON THAT WE
REALLY NEEDED MORE PEOPLE THAT
ARE ACTUALLY KIND OF DOING THE
HARD WORK ON THAT IT TAKES TO
SOLVE PARKS PROBLEMS.
SIXTEEN POINT SIX MILLION OF
THIS AMOUNT IS ALL IS ALSO TO
TAKE CARE OF. OF OUR BUDGET
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE THAT WE'VE
HAD YOU MAY RECALL OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS WE'VE COME BEFORE
THIS BODY FOR A ONE TIME
INCREASE. THAT PERMANENTLY
SOLVES THAT PROBLEM IT ALSO
INCLUDES ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE A GRANTS
PROGRAM ABOUT EIGHTY PERCENT OF
OUR OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
RECREATION ACTUALLY HAPPENS ON
ON STATE LANDS. AND THROUGH THIS
GRANT PROGRAM WE CAN HELP
SUPPORT THAT. THERE'S ALSO ONE
MILLION TO REDUCE BOATING HOUSE
SEARCH THROUGH THE ABANDONED
WATERCRAFT WATERCRAFT ABATEMENT
FUND. A MILLION DOLLARS TO MAKE
PERMANENT A RECRUITMENT IN A
TRAINING PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS WE ARE EMBARKING ON THIS
HIRING EFFORTS. AND THAT WE DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CANCELED OUR
WORKFORCE ON REFLECTS THE
DIVERSITY OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA ON I MIGHT SHARE WITH
YOU THAT IF YOU DRIVE ALONG THE
I. EIGHTY CORRIDOR YOU MAY HAVE
SEEN A RECENT CAMPAIGN THAT
WE'VE LAUNCHED. A RECRUITMENT
CAMPAIGN UP ON A BILLBOARD AND
AT SOME CHOOSE THE PARKS LIFE.
AND.
WE'VE ESTABLISHED KIND OF ON
AMPLIFIED OUR PRESENCE ON THE
INTERNET AND TRYING TO.
REACHED REACH POTENTIAL
CANDIDATES IN A WAY THAT.
KIND OF DEMYSTIFIES KIND OF THE
STATE BUREAUCRATIC PROCESS AND
WHAT IT TAKES TO BECOME AN
EMPLOYEE WITH THE STATE'S TO
WEAR.
EMBARKING ON A ON A REAL TIME
FOCUSED EFFORT IN THAT REGARD.
ALSO THERE'S FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO ADDRESS ACCESS
OPPORTUNITIES WE HELD ON SOME
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT SESSIONS. AND
WE IDENTIFY THAT ONE OF THE
BARRIERS TO ACCESSING OUR PARTS
AS TRANSPORTATION IN SOME AREAS
SO WE REALLY WANT TO USE THAT
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND AND A WAY
TO HELP RESOLVE THAT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
ON AND THEN ALSO THERE WOULD BE
AND TWO YEAR THE
THAT IN THE PAST WE'VE HAD TO
YEAR ANNUAL FUNDING THIS FUNDING
SOURCES FROM THE TIRE RECYCLING
MANAGEMENT FUNDS. TO MAINTAIN
THE SEDIMENT BASINS THAT
PORTERFIELD STATE PARKS
THIS WOULD INSTEAD USE I'M STATE
PARKS AND RECREATION FUND FOR
THAT PURPOSE.
THANK YOU.
A SHOE LA NUMBER THREE PLATES.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE ON PAGE
THIRTY THREE OF YOUR AGENDA.
THIS IS A REQUEST FOR TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
AND. IT IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND TWO POINT
SEVEN MILLION AND TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY. ON FROM OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE TRUST FUND AND
SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE POSITIONS
TO IMPLEMENT ON THE REQUIREMENTS
OF SP TWO FORTY NINE. ON JUST TO
REMIND FOLKS S. B. TWO FORTY
NINE AM SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR.
LAST SUMMER MADE THE OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE RECREATION
PROGRAM A PERMANENT PROGRAM IT
ALSO EXPANDED THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE
DEPARTMENT IN TERMS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL MONITORING IT ALSO
REQUIRES US TO BE MORE
TRANSPARENT AND TO PROVIDE MORE.
ON SCIENCE BASED INFORMATION ON
OUR WEBSITE AND TO ALSO CALL
TOGETHER STAKEHOLDER GROUP TO
BETTER ENGAGE WITH THE PUBLIC AS
WE.
TALK ABOUT HOW CAN THE PUBLIC
IN ALL OF THE VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS BETTER ENGAGE. IN
CALM DISCUSSIONS AND THINKING
ABOUT THE MANAGEMENT OF THIS
IMPORTANT FORM OF RECREATION IN
CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT S. B. TWO
FORTY NINE WAS DEVELOPED THROUGH
A PRETTY ROBUST STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS.
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE BEING
REQUESTED HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE RESOURCE
LEVEL THAT WE IDENTIFIED DURING
THAT STAKEHOLDER PROCESS OVER
THE SUMMER.
THANK YOU.
JUST A PROCEED ONTO ISSUE FOR.
ISSUE FOUR PAGE THIRTY FIVE OF
YOUR AGENDA THIS IS A.
REVENUE GENERATION PROGRAM OUR
EXISTING REVENUE GENERATION
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED
STATUTORILY. BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE I'M SO AS PART
OF OUR OVER ARCHING. GOAL OF
TAKING A LOOK AT HOW WE RESOURCE
AND SUPPORTER IN A SUSTAINABLE
MANNER CALIFORNIA STATE PARK
SYSTEM WE ALSO REVIEWED THIS
PROGRAM AND IDENTIFIED
OPPORTUNITIES TO STRENGTHEN IT
FOR THE FUTURE. ON SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT I WOULD HIGHLIGHT IS
ON. WE HAVE DETERMINED THAT THE
PROGRAMS BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL I
WOULD SHARE WITH YOU THAT LAST
YEAR WE SPENT ABOUT THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION AND IT YIELDED
ABOUT EIGHTEEN MILLION AND
REVENUE.
SO WE THINK THAT IT'S BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL BUT WITH THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD DO WAS PROVIDE US
A LITTLE MORE FLEXIBILITY AND
HOW TO USE THE FUNDS UNDER THE
CURRENT CONSTRUCT.
WE ARE SOMEWHAT LIMITED THAT
ONE WE EARN REVENUE THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM A PORTION OF THAT
REVENUE MUST REMAIN IN THIS POT
OF MONEY THAT JUST GETS PLOWED
ON BACK INTO REVENUE GENERATION
RATHER FOR THE ORGANIZATION.
SO THIS WOULD ALLOW US TO BE
MORE EFFICIENT AND I THINK GET
BACK TO THE ORIGINAL INTENTION
OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT THIS
THIS ON BE ALLOWED TO BE
INVESTED. TO ENHANCE VISITOR
SERVICES IT ALSO MAKES
PERMANENT.
ABOUT FIVE OF OUR EXISTING
REVENUE GENERATION PROJECTS WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT REVENUE GENERATION
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THINGS LIKE
WE'VE CREATED ON NEW TOWERS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE AT HEARST CASTLE.
ENHANCED INPUT IN ELECTRIC PLUG
AND I'M HOOKED UPSET SOME OF OUR
RV SITES ON ALSO ADDED ON
ADDITIONAL CAMP LOOPS TO EXPAND
THE WAYS IN WHICH THE PUBLIC CAN
STAY. AT VARIOUS PARTS OF THOSE
THAT'S KIND OF THE COMPLEMENT OF
THE REVENUE PER NOT PROJECT THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. IT ALSO
WOULD ESTABLISH.
A POT OF MONEY THAT IS
DEDICATED TO SEASONAL WORKERS
WE'VE DETERMINED THAT ONE OF THE
MOST IMMEDIATE WAYS THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY COLLECT REVENUES TO
ACTUALLY HOUSE. OF SEASONAL
STUFF IN THE KIOSK TO WARMLY
WELCOME PEOPLE AND TO COLLECT
THE REVENUE AND INVEST IT BACK
INTO THE SYSTEM. AND WE HAVE
ANNUALLY BEEN USING THIS FOUR
POINT THREE FOUR MILLION FOR
THAT PURPOSE I'M CURRENTLY
THROUGH THE CURRENT CONSTRUCT
THERE'S A TECHNICAL TRANSFER
THAT'S REQUIRED BY THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE. THIS WOULD
ELIMINATE THAT TECHNICAL
TRANSFER AND INSTEAD ESTABLISHED
THIS AND IDENTIFY THIS IS A
PRIORITY.
THANK YOU THERE'S ONE REMAINING
ISSUE.
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
TAKE A BREAK SO THAT I CAN
PRESENTED ITSELF.
HOW MANY FOLKS ARE HERE DO I
GIVE PUBLIC TESTIMONY ON ISSUES
TWO THROUGH FIVE?
IT'S GOT A SHOW OF HANDS.
OKAY.
IF YOU COULD PREPARE TO SPEAK
OUT VERY QUICKLY I'D APPRECIATE
THAT THERE ARE WAITING FOR ME IN
THE HOUSING COMMITTEE APPARENT
YOU FIVE IS THE REVENUE
RESERVATION SYSTEM WE CREATED A
NEW.
RESERVATION SYSTEM.
ON AUGUST FIRST
THIS WOULD INCLUDE ON LITTLE
OVER A MILLION DOLLARS AND SOME
ADMIN POSITIONS TO ALLOW US TO
BETTER SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT SYSTEM.
THANK YOU I'M SORRY TO BE
DISTRACTED.
YOU FINISHED YOUR COMMENTS ON
ALL THE ITEMS LET'S TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND IF YOU'LL FORGIVE ME
FOR TAKING OFF NOW I BELIEVE
MISTER FUNK A.
TO HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT AND I
WILL RETURN VERY SHORTLY. MY
APOLOGIES.
IT FUN SUCH CHAREST NAM
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SPEAKER SO MENTAL SEVEN SILAS
I'M HERE IS THE FOUNDER OF IT
YOU KNOW DOORS BUT ALSO. AS THE
FOUNDER OF WHEN THE ORIGINAL
FOUNDERS HAVE THAT PARKS NOW
COALITION. AND I JUST WANTED A
TESLA HERE IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
SPECIFICALLY ISSUE TOO FOR FIX
OUR PARKS.
I WANTED TO QUICKLY AND THAT
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT IN TERMS
OF BEING OF A SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT JUST AS YOU NOTED AND
ALL THE PROBLEMS THAT THEY'VE
MADE. AND SPECIFICALLY THAT
EVERYTHING THAT WAS PRESENTED TO
SOME LINING WITH THE ORIGINAL
INTENTION OF THE PARKS.
FOR COMMISSION AND.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I WANT TO
STRESS WITH THE AXIS PILOT THAT
THAT WAS MENTIONED LITTLE
INNOVATIVE PROGRAM LIKE THAT IS
CRITICAL TO BE UP CLOSE ONE OF
THOSE EQUITY GAPS WHICH TENDS TO
BE TRANSPORTATION. ALONG WITH
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT WAS
MENTIONED SUCH AS ONE IS THIS.
AGAIN STRESS THE SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF ABOUT A THING OR DOORS
AND AND THE PARTS THAT
COALITION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS HOLLY
MARTINEZ I AM THE DIRECTOR. OF
PROGRAMS AND ADVOCACY AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION AND. AS THE ONLY
STATEWIDE NONPROFIT FOR STATE
PARKS THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION ADVOCATES TO PROTECT
ENHANCE AND EXPAND ALL
CALIFORNIANS ACCESS.
TO THE NATURAL BEAUTY RICH
HISTORY IN OUTSTANDING
RECREATION OPPORTUNITIES OFFERED
BY STATE PARKS.
ON BEHALF OF THE FOUNDATION WE
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSED BUDGET
SPECIFICALLY TO PROVIDE COMMENTS
ON ISSUE NUMBER TO FIX OUR.
PARKS AND WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED INCREASE OF THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR FULL TIME
POSITIONS.
A.
AND RECOGNIZED THE POSITIVE
STEPS TO ADDRESS THE NEED TO
DELIVER CRITICAL SERVICES FOR
FACILITIES AND MAINTENANCE THE
PROTECTION AND PRESERVATION.
OF NATURAL RESOURCES AND
IMPORTANTLY THE INTERPRETATION
AND EDUCATIONAL STAFF THAT SERVE
AS A PROMINENT FACE INTERACTING
WITH THE PUBLIC.
AB WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF APPROPRIATE FOR
MILLION FOR S. B. FIVE FUNDS FOR
THE STATE PARKS
SYSTEM ENHANCEMENTS OF THAT
PROJECT IDENTIFICATION IMPLANT
AND ACTIVITIES CAN COMMENCE.
TO STRATEGICALLY ALLOCATE FUTURE
S. B. FIVE FINDS
AND FINALLY I JUST WANT TO
COMMENT ABOUT A NON VOTE RIGHT
AND JUST QUICKLY ON A BE TWO
FIFTY. AND COMMEND THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THEIR WORK TO I'M
DEVELOP FIFTEEN NEW LOW COST AT
CABINS AT PIPER BIG SIR STEVE
PARK. AND AND START TO IMPLEMENT
LOW COST COASTAL COMBINATIONS SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND WE URGE
THE SUBCOMMITTEE SUPPORT OF THE
BUDGET. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING ON MY NAME IS
KEISHA SEXTET I'M ACTUALLY WITH
LOS ANGELES NEIGHBORHOOD LAND
TRUST AS WELL AS WITH THE PARKS
NOW COALITION. AND I'M BECAUSE
I'M SPEAKING TODAY ON ON IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE TO.
WERE A PARKS NOW COALITION IS
THE ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS
I'M ACTIVISTS COMMUNITY LEADERS.
AS WELL AS.
.
JUST CBO'S WHO SUPPORT PARKS IN
FAN ON.
AND STRONG COMMITMENT TO PART
EQUITY AND WORSE WHERE HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE TOO
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO THE
DIVERSITY RECRUITMENT.
ARE WE WHAT SPECIFICALLY WITH
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND WE
OFTEN HEAR FROM OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO
HAVE STAFF THAT REPRESENT THE
DIVERSITY. AND MAKES US BUT THE
US INCLUDING ME FEEL MORE
WELCOME WE GO TO THE PARK.
AND ALSO HAVING THE LANGUAGE
AND JUST BE IN ASSESSABLE TO US
I'M SO WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT
PROGRAM. SHOULD THERE SHOULD BE
PROGRAM IN PLACE AS WELL AS
RESOURCES TO PREPARE COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR TO ON JOIN THE WORK
FORCE. THANK YOU SO MUCH OF FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND
AGAIN WE SUPPORT.
ISSUE TOO SPECIFICALLY WITH THE
PIPELINE FOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR.
VERY MUCH.
HELLO GOOD MORNING I'M BEN MCCUE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF OUTDOOR
OUTREACH AND WHERE YOU
DEVELOPMENT NONPROFIT OUT OF SAN
DIEGO. AND WE RUN PROGRAMS FOR
YOUTH.
FROM NINE TO TWENTY FOUR YEARS
OLD THAT INCLUDE ALSO ON CAREER
EXPLORATION AND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND POOR HIGHLY
SUPPORTIVE. OF THE MOVE BY THE
DEPARTMENT TO REALLY LOOK AT
INCREASING MORE LOWER LEVEL JOBS
ON PICKET FENCE LEVY AVAILABLE
FOR A LOT OF THE ARE YOU THE
GRADUATES AS WELL.
OF THE SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
INDIVIDUAL YOUTH THAT WE BRING
EVERY YEAR TO STATE PARKS MANY
OF THEM THEIR VERY FIRST TIME
THAT PARKS AND THEY GET REALLY
EXCITED. NAM ABOUT POTENTIAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM IN THESE
PARKS
AND WHEN THEY LEARNED THAT
POTENTIALLY THEY CAN MAYBE SEE A
CAREER IN THE PARKS.
DOT IS A TREMENDOUS ASSET FOR
THEM AND I THINK FROM OUR WORK
THE LENDS YOU CAN REALLY SEE
THAT YOU KNOW PARKS ARE NOT JUST
A NICE TO HAVE BUT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY BE CONNECTED. TO
CRITICAL COMMUTING NEEDS LIKE
YOU DEVELOPMENT AND LIKE CAREER
AND JOB EXPLORATION OPPORTUNITY
SO WE ARE HIGHLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS OF THIS WORK IN THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL. AND BELIEVE THAT
ALIGNS WELL DONE WITH THE GOALS
OF OUR PARKS NOW COALITION AS
WELL AS WITH THE PARKS FORWARD
VISION.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CRYSTAL ALMOST AND I AM OF THE
DIRECTOR OF PROGRAMS THAT
COMMUNITIES FOR CONNECTION WHICH
IS A LOCAL NONPROFIT AND.
LOS ANGELES THAT PROVIDES.
OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES INTERPRETIVE
AND EDUCATIONAL TO.
UNDERSERVED AND
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES.
ME HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE OF
THE BOTTOM NUMBER TWO.
SPECIFICALLY AGAIN WITH THE
DIVERSITY RECRUITMENT.
OUT LOS ANGELES TO HISTORIC
PARK WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
DEVELOP WONDERFUL SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM WITH COMMUNITY LEADERS
WHO HAVE BEEN BECOME TRAINED
ADVOCATES PARK ADVOCATES THE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO FACILITATE
OUTDOOR PROGRAMMING TO THE
COMMUNITIES INTO THEIR YOUTH.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT WE.
WE BELIEVE AND.
HOPE THAT THIS WOULD CONTINUE TO
BE PROVIDED TO THE COMMUNITIES
THAT DESERVE THIS AND I DON'T
USUALLY HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR
PARKS AND WE ARE PROUD PARTNER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARK
LOS ANGELES. STATE HISTORIC PARK
IN PROVIDING THIS PROGRAM AND TO
PROMOTE AUDIX MODOC MODE MODEL
THAT.
SERVES AS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
THE INCLUSIVITY AND THE
COMMITMENT FROM THE DEPARTMENT.
AT THAT VERY MUCH.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
COUNTY HOLLOW MAN I'M WITH
FATHERS AND FAMILIES IN THE PARK
NOW COLLISION I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS ITEM AND THE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IN THE
STATE PARKS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND THROW THEM THOUGH
I'M ON BEHALF BOTTOM LINE
CALIFORNIA AND THEIR LOBBYISTS
WASN'T ABLE TO MAKE IT TODAY SO.
MANASSAS THAT ON ON HIS BEHALF.
JUST WANTED TO FIRST OF ALL I
DON'T CALIFORNIA LINES ITS
COMMENTS WITH EVERYTHING THAT
THAT PARKS NOT COALITION A SAID.
INSTATED REALLY ELOQUENTLY.
AND SPECIFIC TO.
TAUGHT ON CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW
THEY'VE HAVE A REALLY LONG TRACK
RECORD ON WORKING.
ALONG OR ARE COASTAL STATE
PARKS
PERFECT TO.
RESTORATION AND PRESERVATION OF
HABITAT THAT.
IS CRUCIAL FOR THE SNOWY PLOVER
POPULATIONS ALONG THE COAST.
AND REALLY EXCITED TO SEE THE
THE INVESTMENTS FOR THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DIVISION ALONG WITH
EVERYTHING ELSE.
THAT HAS BEEN ARMY STATED.
AND REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUE IN THE PARTNERSHIP WITH
WITH STATE PARKS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND AND LOCALLY AT
THAT IF PARK UNITS THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO ROLL THE
VOTES IN THE END SO I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND
PRESENTATION.
AND WILL NOW MOVE TO ISSUE SIX.
A NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA SNYDER I'M THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION NEWLY APPOINTED
EXECUTIVE SECRETARY AND I'M A
MEMBER OF THE DRY CREEK RANCH
REBOUND POMO INDIANS.
I HAVE TERRY ROBINSON OUR
GENERAL COUNSEL AND W. TREADWAY
ARE THE LEAD OF OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL DEPARTMENT HERE
TODAY IN CASE YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I CAN'T ANSWER IS I'M.
AGAIN NEWLY APPOINTED.
I REQUEST IS ON PAGE THIRTY
EIGHT AND IT'S ISSUE SIX.
WE'RE REQUESTING SIX HUNDRED AND
FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND FROM THE
GENERAL FUND AND TEN POSITIONS
FOR THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
YEAR. AND ONE MILLION TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND FROM
THE GENERAL FUND IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AN ON GOING TO
IMPLEMENT LAWS RELATED TO OUR
WORK.
THE COMMISSION WAS ORIGINALLY
CREATED UNDER STATUTE. UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S FIRST TERM IN OFFICE
AND AS A NINE MEMBER BODY
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR WITH A
MISSION TO PROTECT.
THE CULTURE ESOURCES INCLUDING
GRAVESITES INTO SACRED PLACES OF
CALIFORNIA TRIBES.
INITIALLY THERE WAS LITTLE OR NO
LEGISLATIVE FRAMEWORK FOR THE
WORK OF THE COMMISSION BUT OVER
TIME THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
PASSED A NUMBER OF LOS MORE
EFFECTIVELY PROTECT THESE
IMPORTANT TRAVEL RESOURCES.
THE COMMISSION IS TASKED OF
INTERPRETING IMPLEMENTING AND
ENFORCING THESE LAWS WHICH ON
TOP OF OUR DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONAL DUTIES IN THE
FREQUENT EMERGENCY IS THE TIME
TO CROP UP IN THIS WORK.
REQUIRES A MORE ROBUST LEGAL
TEAM NUMBER CURRENTLY ABLE TO
EMPLOY.
IF APPROVED WE INTEND TO USE THE
RESOURCES TO MEET OUR CURRENT
WORKLOAD DEMANDS A TO FILL
INCREASING STATUTORY OBLIGATIONS
WHICH INCLUDE ENFORCEMENT
COMPLIANCE MEDIATION ADOPTION OF
REGULATIONS TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE
AND CLARITY TO TRIBES AND
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES REGARDING
THE LAWS THAT WE OVERSEE.
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS WE
WILL BE DEVELOPING REGULATIONS
THAT WILL ALLOW US TO COLLECT
FEES ON SACRED LANDS FILE
SEARCHES REQUESTED BY AGENCIES
AND DEVELOPERS PURSUANT TO STATE
LAW. AND THEY SHOULD BE IN PLACE
BY DECEMBER OF THIS YEAR.
WE ANTICIPATE OVER TIME HE'S
HE'S WILL OFFSET THE COST
IDENTIFIED IN OUR REQUEST.
THANK YOU AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE AT THIS TIME.
BUT THANK YOU. UP THE BERMAN
FINANCED YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS.
NO PROBLEM WE SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL AS BUDGET.
THE LA EL.
S. ANY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
UP WE HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE YET THEY HAVE A
MUCH.
WE'LL NOW MOVE TO THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION.
SEVEN EIGHT.
PLEASED WITH THE WAY. THINGS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JENNIFER
LOOK HAS THE I'M THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION.
A AT TO MY RIGHT IS CALLING
CONNOR SYSTEM EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
STARTING WITH ITEM SEVEN ON PAGE
FORTY ONE OF YOUR PACKET AND THE
COMMISSION IS REQUEST TEAM. AT
TWO MILLION THAN THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF GENERAL FUND
MONEY FOR FISCAL YEAR TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO
FUND.
THE INITIAL PHASE OF THE
COMMISSION SPATIALLY INDEX
RECORDS MANAGEMENT SYSTEM UP OR
THE SERBS.
PROJECT A PROJECT TO PROTECT AND
PRESERVE HISTORIC STATE LAND
OWNERSHIP RECORDS.
WHEN COMPLETE DISARMS PROJECT
WILL PROVIDE GEO REFERENCE
DIGITALLY ACCESSIBLE TO AND
ACCESSIBILITY TO THESE LAND
OWNERSHIP RECORDS AND IMPROVE
LEASING WORK FLOW PROCESSES
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM.
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION IS
APPROACHING ITS EIGHTIETH
ANNIVERSARY AND IT MANAGES OVER
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION ACRES
OF.
LAND AND RESOURCES TO CONDUCT
ITS PRIMARY BUSINESS FUNCTIONS
LEAST SEEM AN ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION STAFF RELIES ON
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORICAL RECORDS
THAT DOCUMENT LAND OWNERSHIP.
AND DEFINE THE STATE'S HISTORIC
BOUNDARIES THESE RECORDS INCLUDE
PAPER DOCUMENTS THAT PREDATE THE
ADMINISTER THE ADMISSION OF
PALESTINE INTO THE UNION AND
THROUGH THE PRESENT DAY. THIS
ACCUMULATION OF OVER TWO HUNDRED
YEARS OF RECORDS HAS RESULTED IN
AN ESTIMATED A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
DIFFERENT TYPES. OF RECORDS
CONTAINING OVER FOUR MILLION
DOCUMENTS.
THIS INITIAL PHASE CONSISTING OF
IMPLEMENTATION AND INTEGRATION
OF A LEASE APPLICATION RECORDS
PORTAL INTO AN ENTERPRISE
CONTENT MANAGEMENT SYSTEM WILL
ALLOW INCOMING JURISDICTIONAL
ENQUIRIES AND LEASING
APPLICATIONS TO BE CREATED
DIGITALLY. BASICALLY AN
ELECTRONIC WORK FLOW PROCESS
THIS WILL ALSO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
TO SUBMIT APPLICATIONS AND FEES
FOR THE USE OF STATE LANDS
ELECTRONICALLY.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS.
PROPOSAL.
SO WHERE I WOULD ISSUE A IN
THEM WAS FEDERAL OF IT GREAT
THAT'S OKAY MOVING ON TO ITEM
EIGHT WHICH IS ON PAGE FORTY TWO
OF YOUR PACKET.
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION.
IN THE MANAGEMENT AND LEASING
AND PROTECTION OF STATE LANDS
AND RESOURCES ALSO MANAGES.
THE OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS I'M WITH IN STATE
WATERS.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE FOR.
A LEASES FOR OFFSHORE PLATFORMS
AND ONE OFFSHORE ISLAND THIS
REQUEST.
IS THAT.
FOR A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED AND
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS TO
PERMANENTLY SECURE PLUG AND
ABANDONED THIRTY TWO WELLS ON
PLATFORM HOLLY AND SHORES OWN
PEERS OFFSHORE THE CITY OF THE
LEAD AND SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
THIS CONSTITUTES ONE.
OF THOSE OFFSHORE OPERATIONS
THAT I JUST MENTIONED.
AND IN ADDITION WE'RE ALSO
REQUESTING THAT.
AT THAT AT THAT TOTAL AMOUNT TO
COVER THE PLUGIN AN ABANDONMENT
OF AN ADDITIONAL FORTY NINE
WELLS LOCATED ON RINCON ISLAND.
AT MUSCLE SHORES OFF SHORE
VENTURA COUNTY.
SPECIFICALLY WE ARE REQUESTING
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS I'M
IN GENERAL FUND IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FORTY MILLION
OF GENERAL FUND MONIES IN TWO
THOUSANDNINETEEN TWENTY. AND
TEN MILLION.
TEN POINT FIVE MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND MONIES INCH WANT
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND TO FACILITATE THE PLUGIN AND
ABANDONMENT OF THESE OFFSHORE
FACILITIES. THE LESSEES FOR
THESE FACILITIES THAT ECHO LLC
AND RINCON ISLAND LIMITED
PARTNERSHIP FILED FOR BANKRUPTCY
IN APRIL TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
AND AUGUST TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
RESPECTIVELY. NOTWITHSTANDING
THE COMMISSION'S ACTIVE
INVOLVEMENT TO PROTECT THE
STATE'S INTEREST IN BOTH
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDINGS THE
BANKRUPTCY COURTS REJECTED THAT
ECHOES AND RINCON ISLANDS
LIMITED PARTNERSHIPS LEASE
OBLIGATIONS THE PLUGIN ABANDON
THE OIL AND GAS WELLS.
IN THE ABSENCE OF THE LAST SEAT
TO ASSUME THIS RESPONSIBILITY
AND PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY IN THE COASTAL MARINE
ENVIRONMENT. THE COMMISSION MUST
UNDERTAKE THIS PLUGIN AND
ABANDONMENT WORK AND THE
ULTIMATE DECOMMISSIONING OF THE
FACILITIES.
AS.
PART OF THIS A.
WORK THAT WE HAVE BEEN
CONDUCTING RELATING TO THE
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDINGS ON THEM
PLANNING FOR THE PLUGIN AND
ABANDONMENT.
WORK FOR THE BOTH OF THESE
OFFSHORE FACILITIES WE HAVE ALSO
LEARNED A GREAT DEAL AND ARE
APPLYING THOSE LESSONS LEARNED
TO OUR.
EXISTING IN OIL AND GAS LESSEES
THAT CURRENTLY MANAGE AND
OPERATE OIL AND GAS OPERATIONS
OFF OF THREE PLATFORMS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND SO I'M
HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT THAT OR
ANSWER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU HAVE
ANY COMING UP ON EITHER ISSUE
SEVEN OR EIGHT BOTH.
ISSUE IT ENDED UP TO THE
PRIVATE FINANCE WE JUST KNOW
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS NO
ISSUES WITH THE PROPOSED
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
IDENTIFIED IN THE AGENDA.
THANK YOU EARLIER EVERY TO IN
THOSE WITH THE ALEJO WE DO
RECOMMEND M. ADOPTING THIS
PROPOSAL THESE ARE.
.
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC AN
ENVIRONMENTAL RISKS THAT THAT
THESE WELLS POSE.
A COUPLE OF THE POINTS THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN MENTIONED IT COULD
BE THAT THE STATE COSTS AND UP
LOWER AND AND LIKELY WILL BE
LOWER THAN THEIR REQUEST BEFORE
YOU BECAUSE THE COMMISSION IS IN
NEGOTIATIONS WITH FORMER LESSEES
TO GET SOME OF THE MONEY BACK
SO.
THE.
JUST FOR THAT SO YOU'RE AWARE I
THINK WE'VE WE AGREE THAT THIS
FUNDING SHOULD BE PROVIDED NOW
BUT HOPEFULLY THE STATE COSTS
WILL END UP LOWER.
AND AS WAS MENTIONED THERE ARE
SOME OTHER PLATFORM SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE STATE'S
TAKING STEPS TO. LIMIT OUR
LIABILITY FOR FOR THE FUTURE FOR
THOSE OTHER PLATFORMS.
AND THEN FINALLY AS NOTED IN
YOUR AGENDA THESE WERE FUNDING
REQUEST BEFORE YOU ARE NOT THE
TOTAL COST TO ADDRESS THESE
FACILITIES THIS IS JUST THE
PLUGGING AN ABANDONMENT THERE
WILL BE ADDITIONAL COSTS.
ASSOCIATE WITH DECOMMISSIONING
ULTIMATELY AND SOME BIG
DECISIONS AHEAD AS WELL HOW WILL
THEY BE TO DECOMMISSION WILL
THEY BE LEFT IN PLACE WILL BABY
TRANSFORM WILL THEY BE REMOVED.
SO THAT THEIR FUTURE DECISIONS
THAT WILL COME BEFORE YOU TO SO
AS NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA WE DO
RECOMMEND.
THE LEGISLATURE ADOPTS
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
FOR THE COMMISSION TO PROVIDE
YOU AN UPDATE ON SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES.
IN THE COMING YEAR BY NEXT
JANUARY AS YOU DELIBERATE AT
BEGINNING. TO CONSIDER AT NEXT
YEAR'S BUDGET WHAT IS THE STATUS
OF THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
FROM THE FORMER LET'S SEE AND
WHAT STEPS HAS THE COMMISSION
TAKEN TO LIMIT FUTURE LIABILITY
AND THEN FINALLY.
WHAT'S THE STATUS OF THE WORK
ON THESE PROJECTS.
BUT THEY'VE ALLEGE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DO HAVE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'RE GONNA SKIP NINE REAL AND
GO TO ISSUE TEN IF THAT IS OKAY.
FUND THAT WILL BE DIPLOMA
FORTUNE FIVE PROTECTION. PATHWAY
CONSERVATION CORPS
.
ALREADY
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING.
CAN PIMLOTT THAT DIRECTOR CAL
FIRE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT TODAY I ISSUE NUMBER TEN
IS A COOPERATIVE A BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL.
WITH THE BETWEEN CAL FIRE AYE
AND THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS.
DIRECTOR SITE TO.
FROM THE CORE IS HERE WITH US
TODAY. AS WELL AS OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF FIRE PROTECTION CAL
FIRE AT CHU TYLER.
ITEM TEN REQUEST A TOTAL OF
NINE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
IN A GENERAL FUND AND ELEVEN
POSITIONS. ARE IN THE CENTURY
THIS IS A A FOR FULLY FUNDING
ONE FIRE Q. IT BUTTE FIRE CENTER
TO BE FULL TIME AVAILABLE TO
CALIFORNIA.
TO CRUISE AT THE CAMERA FIRE
CENTER TO BE AVAILABLE FULL TIME
TO CALIFORNIA. AND MAKING
PERMANENT TO ADDITIONAL FIRE
CREWS AT THE PLASTER CENTER ARE
IN PLASTER COUNTY THIS SO
SOLIDIFIES AN AGREEMENT WE
ALREADY HAVE IN A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS. TO ENSURE THAT THE GOT
CREWS THAT ARE ALREADY THERE ARE
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT FUNDED AND
COMMITTED AND AVAILABLE TO THE
EMERGENCY FIRE AND AND OTHER
EMERGENCY RESPONSE EFFORTS AYE
NEEDS OF THE STATE. AT THE SAME
TIME TO CONTINUE THE FIRE
PREVENTION AND FUELS TREATMENTS
EFFORTS THAT WE'RE DOING A
ACROSS THE STATE.
BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE THEM.
I THINK A MUCH.
AS PART OF FINANCE I YOU KNOW IF
THERE WAS ACTUALLY OTHER FOLKS
FROM.
TELL US IN HERE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE WORSE MINUTES SUPPORTIVE
OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S.
FOR ALEJO.
UP PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEN ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT WELL THEN WE'RE GONNA
MOVED ISSUE ELEVEN.
THAT.
ISSUE ELEVEN THANK YOU ARE
MOVING ALONG.
THAT PICKED UP THE TEMPO.
.
I ISSUE ELEVEN IS FOR.
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR ACQUISITION OF TWENTY NINE
ACRES ADJACENT TO THE HOWARD
FOREST TELETECH BASE.
ARE IN MENDOCINO COUNTY THIS IS
A KEY PIECE OF. OUR OF LAND
ADJACENT TO THE HELL ATTACK BASE
THE APPROACH AND DEPARTURE FOR
THE HELICOPTER. ARE IS RIGHT OUT
OVER THIS PARCEL OF LAND
ADJACENT TO HIGHWAY ONE TO ONE
IT'S KEY THAT WE MAINTAIN THAT
BUFFER AROUND THE HELIPAD BASE
SO THAT THE.
AIRCRAFT CAN COME AND GO.
SAFELY.
AND TO ENSURE WERE NOT YET IN
IN.
IMPEDING ANY FUTURE OR THERE
ISN'T ANY FUTURE DEVELOPMENT ON
THAT PARCEL THE COULD NOT IMPEDE
THE FLIGHT PATH OF THE
HELICOPTER AND PROVIDING SAFETY
ISSUES.
I THINK ANY OF YOU AND GERMAN
HAVING THE AT DIFFERENT FINANCE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
MINISTRIES IN SUPPORT OF AT
THIS.
THANK YOU PLAYER.
REQUIRED TODAY A PUBLIC COMMENT.
A CRISIS IN THE COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT WHOM I LOVE ISSUE
TWELVE.
THANK YOU ISSUE TWELVE IS
AVIATION PARTS AND LOGISTICS
CONTRACT FUNDING THIS IS
REQUESTING A ONE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS OF ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. TO FUND OUR
ACQUISITION AND LOGISTICS
CONTRACT OFF FROM A FISCAL YEAR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THIS CONTRACT IS
CRITICAL FOR CAL FIRES AVIATION
PROGRAM AS WE ACQUIRE APART FROM
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND OFTEN
AROUND THE WORLD TO ENSURE WE
HAVE. OF THE AVAILABLE PARTS
NEEDED TO KEEP TRACK HELLFIRE IS
AVIATION PROGRAM OFFLINE
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR AT PIGGLY
DURING THESE CRITICAL FIRE
SEASON EVENTS THIS ONE SURE THE
CONTRACT. HAS THE APPROPRIATE
FUNDING TO DO THAT.
I THINK VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT
FINANCE.
LL STILL GOT NOTHING NOTHING.
PUBLIC.
THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING AND QUESTIONS IN THE
COMMITTEE.
NONE.
YOU THIRTEEN.
MORNING ISSUE THIRTEEN US
HELICOPTER ACQUISITION AND
SUPPORT OUR THIS IS A THREE
YEAR.
BUDGETED PROPOSAL.
TO PROVIDE A VARIETY OF SUPPORT
AND FUNDING FOR REPLACING CAL
FIRES ARE AGING HELICOPTER FLEET
THIS WILL PROVIDE THE
PROCUREMENT OF THE ADDITIONAL
ELEVEN. HELICOPTERS ARE OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS THERE'S FUNDING
OF SHEETS PROVIDING I CAN
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DETAIL THERE
BUT IT WILL ALSO PROVIDE.
THE FUNDING SUPPORT FOR THE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS ARE AND
SUPPORT COST NECESSARY TO
IMPLEMENT AT THE NEW HELICOPTER
PROGRAM.
AB ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
BUT BERMAN APPLIANCE
BUT WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL.
L. L..
IF YOU ACCEPT COMMENTS AROUND
EIGHT HUNDRED OUT.
THANK YOU I'M ACTUALLY AS OF THE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
I ALWAYS KNOW IN JANUARY.
THERE WAS A LINE ITEM FOR HOW
GOVERNOR PLACE WHEN WE
RECOMMENDED HOLDING OPEN ABOUT
TIME. I BASED ON LIKE OF
INFORMATION. RELATED TO THOSE
THAT EMPLOYER COSTS ARE FOR
SUPPORT CAP WILDLY. THIS LETTER
DOES PROVIDE A LOT OF THAT
INFORMATION AND SO AT THIS TIME
AYE WE OFTEN MORE CONCERNED WITH
THE PROPOSAL.
BUT THAT VERY MUCH UP PUBLIC
COMMENT.
SEEING NO VOTE.
WE HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS.
EXCUSE ME.
I'M JIM ANY AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
FOR SIKORSKI AIRCRAFT
MANUFACTURE THE BLOCK KONKAN HIM
ALSO AN ENGINEER THAT WAS ON THE
ORIGINAL FIREHAWK PROGRAM AND
ALSO A HELICOPTER PILOT. AND I'M
AYE WE JUST WANTED TO COME UP
HERE TODAY TO KIND OF TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE BACKGROUND
OF THIS AIRCRAFT THAT YOU GUYS
ARE SELECTING OR. YOU'RE LOOKING
TO PURCHASE.
A WHEN I WAS ON THE PROGRAM THIS
WAS AN EIGHT YEAR QUEST TO
DEVELOP THIS PARTICULAR PRODUCT
LINE.
FOR THE FIRST TWO YEARS WERE
SPENT JUST PICKING OUT THE BLACK
HAWK ITSELF TO BE ABLE TO
OPERATE IN THE CALIFORNIA TRAIN
UNDER THE ALTITUDE AND
TEMPERATURE CONDITIONS THESE
GUYS ARE FACING.
AND THEY TANK THAT IS ON THE
BLACK CAUCUS A THREE YEAR
DEVELOPMENT THAT WAS JUST TO.
DESIGN THE AIRCRAFT TO TAKE
ABOARD SPECIFICATIONS
TO BE ABLE TO MEET THE EXACT
EFFICIENCY THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
DROPPING WATER. AND THE
CAPABILITY THAT THESE GUYS NEEDS
IN THE CONDITIONS THAT THEY'RE
FIGHTING EVERY DAY THE PUTTING
THEMSELVES IN HARM'S WAY AND YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE. YOU WANNA
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE THE SAFEST
AIRCRAFT IN THIS WAS A MILITARY
AIRCRAFT POINT FOR THE BILL TO
FIELD POINT FOR THE SAFETY AND
EFFECTIVENESS.
SO I'M JUST HERE TO FOR ARMY
OFFICER CORPS SKI AIRCRAFT TO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THOSE.
KNOCKED ON IT'S GONNA TRIPLE
THEIR POTENT PRODUCTIVITY FOR
THE STATE IT'S GONNA TRIPLE THE
RANGE OF THE KING OF THE
CAPABILITY IT'S GOING TO TRIPLE
THE WATER DROP. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY AN INITIAL ATTACK
WHEN MINUTES MATTER THOUGHTS
WHEN THE AIRCRAFT AS THEY ARE
AND DESIGNED TO DO.
AND WE'RE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AS WELL SUPPORT CAUGHT
FIRE. THINKING.
I THINK YOU MUCH.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT AND
OTHERS WERE HOLDING THIS OPEN.
A A QUESTIONS OF GREENS PASSION.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS A REALLY
GOOD. AIRCRAFT AND AND WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
.
THE REST OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS KNOW WE TOOK A VERY VERY
DEEP AND A LONG DIVE AND ALL OF
THIS I.
IF YOU'VE BEEN IN MY OFFICE YOU
KNOW THERE ARE A FEW.
THINGS THAT FLY ON THE WALL
HOLES.
AND I I KNOW THAT THERE WAS
SOME CONTROVERSY IN THE BIDDING
AND AND A LOT OF.
CLAIMS MADE ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER.
AS IS OUR CUSTOM WE DUG DOWN
DEEP INTO IT ASKED.
AND DOUBLE LAST AND QUITE
FRANKLY. OF FOR A I THINK A
SMALL AMOUNT PERHAPS OF
ADDITIONAL MONEY THIS IS A.
VERY GOOD AIRCRAFT AND HAS.
HUGE CAPABILITIES FOR THE
FUNDAMENTAL MISSION.
AND FOR THE SAFETY OF PILOTS IN
THE GROUND CREW SO I'M I'M GOING
TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS WHEN IT
COMES FOR.
US YOU KNOW THE QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE THANKS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED APPRECIATE LA OF
HAVING HIM COME AT THE END.
WE ARE NOW WITH THIS LIST
MULLIN HERE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
OUT ISSUE NINE AT THE SAME JUST
GO BAY CONSERVATION DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION
.
A PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY NAME IS
LARRY GOLD SPENT ON EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE.
SAN FRANCISCO BAY CONSERVATION
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION
APPRECIATE YOU HAVING US WITH
YOU TODAY. THE ISSUE YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU IS ESSENTIALLY HOW BE
C. D. C.
SHOULD PAY FOREIGN ENHANCED AND
INCREASED ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM.
CURRENTLY BCD WHICH HAS APPROVED
APPROXIMATELY FIVE THOUSAND OR
SO PERMITS AND AMENDMENTS TO
PERMITS INCONSISTENCY
DETERMINATIONS AND THE LIKE. HAS
A ENFORCEMENT BACKLOG OF TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT OPEN CASES
WITH THREE INDIVIDUALS BEING
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEM IN OUR
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM.
ONLY TWENTY THREE OF THOSE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT OPEN CASES
ARE ACTUALLY ACTIVE
BECAUSE CANDIDLY ENFORCEMENT
TAKES AN AWFUL LOT OF TIME AND
WHEN YOU HAVE ONLY THREE PEOPLE.
IT TAKES OF THE TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
THAT BACKLOG HAS ACTUALLY
INCREASED BY MORE THAN FIFTY
PERCENT.
DURING THE PAST TEN YEARS.
WHEN I JOIN BE CDC IS ACTIVE
DIRECTOR IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE.
.
I DISCOVERED THAT THERE WAS NO
PRIOR TO STATION OF CASES.
THAT BC DC HAD SPENT THE
PREVIOUS DECADE ESSENTIALLY
LOOKING AT MUCH SMALLER CASES
WITH THIS MUCH SMALLER FINES AND
THERE WAS VERY VERY LITTLE
PARTICIPATION BY THE
COMMISSIONERS ON ENFORCEMENT
COMMITTEE. TO ACTUALLY PROVIDE
DIRECTION AND GUIDANCE AS WELL
AS.
LOOKING AT LARGER TYPES OF
CASES.
SINCE THEN OF AS PART OF OUR
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN STRATEGIC
PLAN WE HAVE DEVELOPED A MUCH
MORE DATA DRIVEN. ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM WHICH CONCENTRATES ON
ACTUALLY DEVELOPING A POINT
SYSTEM A TO TAKE A LOOK AT HARM
TO THE BAY. HARM TO ACCESS TO
THE BAY AS WELL AS TO THE SYSOON
MARSH.
AND THEREFORE WE HAVE MOVED TO
LARGER SCALE CASES WITH
COMPLIANCE POTENTIAL.
BECAUSE THOSE LARGER CASES
SIMPLY CAUSE MORE HARM TO THE
BAY OR DENY MORE OF THE PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE BAY.
AND AS A RESULT WHAT WE HAVE
DONE IS INCREASE OUR
PRIORITIZATION ACTUALLY DEVELOP
A STRATEGY WITH REGARD HOW TO DO
ENFORCEMENT. AND DO SO WITH
GUIDANCE FROM OUR COMMISSIONERS
LET ME SAY SOMETHING ABOUT THE
BC DC COMMISSIONERS.
THEY NINE OF THEM ARE COUNTY
SUPERVISORS FOR OUR LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS FROM CITY
COUNCIL AND OUT OF THE FIVE
MEMBERS OF THE ENFORCEMENT
COMMITTEE IT BC DC THREE ARE
THOSE LOCALLY ELECTED OFFICIALS
FROM AROUND THE BAY. THEY HANDLE
ENFORCEMENT CASES ALL THE TIME
AS PART OF THEIR DAY JOB AS IT
WERE THEY UNDERSTAND HOW
ENFORCEMENT WORKS WITH REGARD TO
PLANNING IN PERMITS.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN ABSOLUTELY
WONDERFUL IN DIRECTING AND. AND
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE TO THE
STAFF AS WE TAKE A LOOK AND
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN PRIORITIZE
AND HOW WE CAN MOVE ON.
WE HAVE RECEIVED TREMENDOUS
SUPPORT FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE FOR WHICH WE
ARE TREMENDOUSLY GRATEFUL AND
WE'RE USING TOOLS WHICH YOU THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED US ABOUT
TEN YEARS AGO WHICH WE DID NOT
HAVE BEFORE. WITH REGARD TO HOW
WE CAN ACTUALLY DO OUR
ENFORCEMENT WORK.
THE KEY HERE AND THIS IS WHERE
ALL PROBABLY END BECAUSE I'M
SURE YOU HAVE QUESTIONS AND AND
WILL ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT THE
FUNDING MECHANISM.
IS THAT THE CDC DOESN'T WANNA BE
THE COP BEHIND THE BILLBOARD IN
THE RURAL HIGHWAY WHO TRIES TO
CATCH PEOPLE GOING SEVENTY MILES
AN HOUR IN A SIXTY FIVE MILE PER
HOUR ZONE.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TAKE
A LOOK AT THE LARGE SCALE
PROBLEMS AND CHALLENGES ALONG IT
INSIDE THE BAY? AND WORK
COOPERATIVELY WITH THOSE PERMIT
HOLDERS
AND THAT'S THE THING THAT BC DC
HAS HISTORICALLY DONE WE DON'T
START A PROCESS BY SENDING A
LETTER AND SAYING.
NOW THAT'S THE PROBLEM INSTEAD
WE HAVE SITE VISITS WE WORK
PERMIT HOLDERS WHETHER THEY BE
PUBLIC AGENCIES ARE PRIVATE
PRIVATE DEVELOPERS AND WE TRIED
TO GET AGREEMENTS BECAUSE
CANDIDLY GETTING AN AGREEMENT IS
AN AWFUL LOT QUICKER. AN AWFUL
LOT MORE SATISFYING AND CANDIDLY
SOLVES THE PROBLEM A WHOLE LOT
EARLIER THAN HAVING TO GO
THROUGH THE TO GAUGE SO THAT'S
WHAT WE TRY TO DO.
THE THE ISSUE BEFORE YOU IS HOW
BC DC CAN EXPAND THAT
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM.
AND WHAT WE WOULD NEED AT BC DC
IS A FULL TIME ATTORNEY WHO
HANDLES ENFORCEMENT. INSTEAD OF
OUR CHIEF COUNSEL WHO SPENDING
EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT OF HIS TIME
ON ENFORCEMENT AND FIFTEEN
PERCENT OF HIS TIME ON THE OTHER
STUFF THAT I WANTED TO SPEND
TIME.
AS WELL AS A SENIOR LEVEL
MANAGER WHO CAN MANAGE THOSE
THREE PEOPLE INSURE THAT THE
DIRECTION IS BEING FOLLOWED IT
ACTUALLY HELPED DEVISE THAT
STRATEGY. AND ALSO HELPED DEVISE
A TRUE COMPLIANCE PROGRAM.
SO THE ISSUE YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU
AS IS THE REQUEST BY P. CDC TO
ALLOW US TO USE FUNDS FROM THE
BAY FILL. AND ABATEMENT FUND
INTO WHICH FINDS ARE ACTUALLY
DEPOSITED.
TO PROVIDE A STABLE SOURCE FOR
AT LEAST THREE TO FIVE YEARS FOR
THOSE TWO POSITIONS
AND OUR ESTIMATES ARE THAT IF
WE.
ACTUALLY CONTINUE TO HAVE LARGE
ENFORCEMENT CASES WHICH ARE.
HOPEFULLY NEGOTIATED SOLUTIONS
AND SETTLEMENTS THOSE FUNDS WILL
ESSENTIALLY PAID BACK THE FUND
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS AND AND WE
WILL TIE THOSE TWO POSITIONS
DIRECTLY TO THOSE FUNDS.
SO THAT WHEN THOSE FUNDS IF
THOSE FUNDS AND IF THAT FUND
DOESN'T IS NO LONGER SOLVENT WE
SIMPLY WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO FUND
THOSE TO.
SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UP.
SIMILAR.
THANK YOU MISTER MISTER RIGHT
CHAIRED THANK YOU DIRECTOR FOR
THE PRESENTATION I GUESS I HAVE
TO TAKE OUT THE COP BEHIND THE
BILLBOARD REFERENCE IN MY
TALKING.
HERE SINCE YOU'VE ACTUALLY.
ACTIVELY ADDRESS THAT CONCERN
BUT I AM A BIG FAN OF THE CDC AS
A BAY AREA NATIVE. HAVING GROWN
UP THERE THE BAY WOULD NOT BE
WHAT IT IS TODAY WITHOUT THE
FINAL WORK AT THE CDC IN THE
STEWARDSHIP.
ALL OF THE ORGANIZATION I KNOW
WE'RE GONNA BE HOLDING THIS
ITEM.
OPEN BECAUSE I JUST HAVE SOME
FUNDAMENTAL CONCERNS ABOUT THE
MECHANISM HERE AND MAYBE WE
WRITER.
TALK OUR WAY THROUGH THAT SO.
I WANT BE CDC TO CONTINUE ITS
ITS CRITICAL MISSION OF OF
REGULATION AND OVERSIGHT THE
BUDGET REQUEST THOUGH.
I THINK PUTS US ON OUR ON THE
WRONG PATH AND I CAN BE SWAYED
ON THIS BUT.
.
THERE'S SOME FUNDAMENTAL
CONCERNS I HAVE THAT WERE ASKED
TO APPROVE MORE STAFF FOR
ENFORCEMENT. USING ENFORCEMENT
PROCEEDS RIGHT SO.
I NEED TO GET TO A COMFORT
LEVEL WITH THAT AND I'M I'M NOT.
THERE RIGHT NOW SO I THINK IT
INCENTIVIZE IS MORE AGGRESSIVE
ENFORCEMENT FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE
OF REPLENISHING OUR COFFERS A I
THINK WE COULD SOMEHOW CRAFT A
BETTER WAY TO DO THIS SO.
.
THAT REQUEST COMES WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF A COUPLE OF YEARS A
PRETTY VISIBLE ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITY AND FROM WHAT I CAN
GATHER.
ENFORCEMENT WAS IN A SURLY
PRIORITY UNDER THE PREVIOUS
DIRECTOR NOW IT SEEMS TO BE
RAMPING UP I THINK SOME LONG
TIME STAKEHOLDERS.
AROUND THE BAY FRONT.
HAVE BEEN SHOCKED A LITTLE BIT
AT THE NEW.
ENFORCEMENT REGIME.
I THERE A COUPLE OF ISSUES I
THINK BETTER ARE SORT OF IN THE
PROCESS OF BEING MEDIATED BEING
WORKED THROUGH SO. I'M NOT GOING
TO BE.
COMMENTING ON ANYTHING SPECIFIC
IN THAT REGARD IT'S REALLY ABOUT
THE GAME PLAN GOING FORWARD NOW
I LIKE THAT YOU ARE.
PRIORITIZING.
AND THERE'S SOME ADDITIONAL
THOUGHT GOING INTO THIS.
AND YOU KNOW I'M A PRETTY.
ENVIRONMENTAL GUY I'VE PRETTY A
VOTING RECORD IN THAT REGARD BUT
I'M CONCERNED THAT.
YOU KNOW IF IT FEELS ARBITRARY.
IN ANY WAY.
YOU KNOW WE'RE GIVING
GOVERNMENT A BAD NAME IN THE BAY
AREA.
AND HAVE FOR BE WE DON'T WANT
TO DO THAT RIGHT THAT I'M
CONCERNED THAT THIS IS HOW FUNDS
ARE INTERACTING WITH THEIR
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
AND I'VE HEARD SOME TROUBLING
STORIES SO.
I THINK YOU'RE PROBABLY ON THE
RIGHT. GENERAL PATH HERE.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO ESTABLISH
SOME CONSISTENCY GOING FORWARD
THAT. ON THE STAKEHOLDERS CAN
SORT OF COUNT ON LIKE OF IT THIS
IS HOW BE CDC OPERATES.
BUT I ALSO DON'T WANT.
THIS TO BE.
AYE HEAVY HANDED KIND OF A SET
UP WHERE YOU GOT IT FORSMAN
BEING DONE REALLY TO KEEP.
STAFFING THESE POSITIONS GOING
FORWARD THERE ARE SO MANY ISSUES
GOING FOR WITH BAY LEVEL RISE.
YOU FOLKS ARE GONNA HAVE. YOUR
HANDS FULL AS WE ALL DEAL.
WITH A GRAPPLING WITH THE
CHANGING BAY LINE I IN THE BAY
AREA SAID THEY'RE GOING TO BE
SOME OTHER LARGER PRIORITIES.
AND AND BC HE SEES ROLE REALLY
IS GOING TO BEOME EVEN MORE
CRITICAL THAT HAS BEEN IN THE
PAST.
SO I DON'T WANT TO GET OFF TRACK
IN THIS REGARD ON I JUST NEED TO
GET TO A BETTER COMFORT LEVEL
ABOUT HOW THE AGENCY IS AB
APPROACHING. ENFORCEMENT AND
REALLY WHAT THE BUDGET MECHANISM
IT IS IN THAT REGARD SO.
THERE SYNC ACCOUNT RECESSION
WILL BE HAVING MY DISTRICT ALONG
WITH SENATOR HEALTH. AND NOW
SOME OF THE OTHER KEY PLAYERS
THERE SAY LOOK FOR THAT
CONVERSATION AND I THE COURT TO.
WORKING WITH THE AGENCY TO SEE
IF THERE'S MAYBE A BETTER WAY TO
APPROACH THIS.
I THINK A SMALL DITCH DID YOU
WATER.
SPARTAN ANYWAY.
YEAH I I LEFT LIMIT RESPONSE
SAYING I.
I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND AND TOTALLY
SUPPORT.
SAYING ESPECIALLY ABOUT
CONSISTENT.
I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT A REGULATORY AGENCY CAN DO
FOR THE PUBLIC IS DEMONSTRATE
CONSIST.
BECAUSE THAT ACTUALLY.
TELLS THE PUBLIC THAT THE
EVERITT REGULATORY AGENCY
UNDERSTANDS WHAT'S GOING ON OUT
THERE.
AN ACTUALLY HAS A PLAN TO DEAL
WITH AND MAP PLAN CAN BE COUNTED
ON IN FUTURE YEARS.
AND. CANDIDLY WE HAVEN'T BEEN
CONSISTENT AT THE
SEE WITH REGARD TO HOW WE
ENFORCE
AND AND THAT'S FOR AN AWFUL LOT
OF REASONS SO WE ARE MOVING
TOWARD CONSISTENT.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU MOVE TOWARD A
NEW KIND OF PROGRAMMER
REINVIGORATE A PROGRAM IS THAT
YOU UPSET THE EXISTING APPLE
CART.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT WHICH IS THAT WHICH IS
THAT ALL OF A SUDDEN BC DC IS
SEEN AS.
THERE ACTUALLY BEING SERIOUS
ABOUT ENFORCEMENT ON A LARGE
SCALE SO GETTING TO THAT POINT
OF CONSISTENCY IS NOT EASY.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE HAVE A PRIORITIZATION.
WHY YOU HAVE TO ALSO INTEGRATE
THAT PRIORITIZATION SYSTEM WITH
THOSE CASES WITH THE CASES
YOU'RE ALREADY WORKING ON.
AND YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO MERGE THAT TOGETHER AND
INTEGRATE IT SO THAT IN THE NEXT
THREE TO FIVE YEARS WHAT BC DC
IS DOING BECOMES EXPECTED.
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
ABOUT WHAT ABOUT BECOMING
EXPECTED TO A SENSE OF
CONSISTENCY IS THAT PROBABLY
DOES MORE TO ENCOURAGE
COMPLIANCE WITH PERMITS.
THAN ANYTHING ELSE
BECAUSE IF THE PUBLIC SECTOR
PERMIT HOLDERS IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR PERMIT HOLDERS RECOGNIZE
AND UNDERSTAND HOW BC DC
APPROACHES ENFORCEMENT ON THOSE
LARGE SCALE CASES.
THEY HAVE A REASON TO LOOK AT
HOW THEY'RE WORKING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY CAN LOOK AT US AND SAY
WE ARE DEFINITELY A COMPLIANCE
AND WE CAN ACTUALLY SHOW THAT
OFF.
A THINK YOU VERY MUCH THAT WE'RE
WELL OUT OF ORDER BUT PART
FINANCE.
INTERRUPTED DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JUST NOTE THAT THE
COMMITTEES.
TOOK ACTION
REDUCE REDUCE THEIR PREPARATION
FOR THE.
BAY FILL CLEAN UP ABATEMENT
FUND.
AT A HEARING.
EARLIER APRIL THANK YOU LL BE
EVERY TRAILERS OF LA NO NOT YET
SO THERE THERE IS A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT TO THIS REQUEST
BEFORE YOU THAT YOU'VE ACTUALLY
ALREADY ACTED ON SO WITHOUT
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT WE DON'T
HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. THAT THEY GRADUALLY
THIS OPEN BUT PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE I KNOW WOULD MISS
MILLER YES WHAT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS IN
COMMITTEE.
AB THANKS VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THAT.
I THINK WE'RE GONNA WAIT FOR.
A GERMAN LIVING TO COME BACK SO
THAT WE CAN.
.
WE CAN KASSOVITZ
THROUGH.
FOR THE FIFTY ONE FIFTY THROUGH
IT.
FIFTY THREE TO FIFTY FIVE.
A AMEND TECHNICALLY SUBTLE.
BLOOM.
FAR.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON I.
NEW LOOKING FOR MOTION TO ADOPT
SAPPHIC EMENDATIONS RIVER ONLY
ISSUE THREE.
BLOOM.
BLOOM FONG NO.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON MORE.
MOTION TO ADOPT AB STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR VOTE ONLY
FISH.
TO.
LITTLE TO NO.
ALL.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON
.
OKAY VOTING ON ITEMS YOU HEARD
ON ISSUE TO LOOK FOR MOTION.
HELLO. FONG NO.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON MORE.
BUT ISSUES THREE.
BLOOM.
FONG I.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
BOND ISSUE FOR.
BLOOM FONG AYE.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
BUT FISH
FIVE.
BLOOM KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
BUT ISSUE SIX.
BLOOM.
FONG I KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON ALL.
ISSUE SEVEN.
BLOOM FONG AYE KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
I ISSUE EIGHT.
BLOOM.
FONG I.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
NICE OPEN ISSUED CHEN.
HELLO.
FONG I KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
BUT ISSUE ELEVEN.
BLOOM FONG AYE KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
AND THE ISSUE TWELVE.
BLOOM. FONG AYE KALRA.
MULLIN. PATTERSON. IN ISSUE
THIRTEEN IS HOLD OPEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH
I APOLOGIZE WE'RE GONNA PULL
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY SIX WITH
ABOUT ONLY COUNTER FOR FUTURE
AGENDA. AND A MISTER BLOOM IS
GOING TO ADD ON.
WEEKS BACK
WE'RE BACK.
AND.
ONCE AGAIN I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
DESTRUCTION BUT IT LOOKS LIKE
I'M NOT NECESSARY TO AYE
CONCLUDING THIS PROCESS.
ALTHOUGH MY VOTE IS NECESSARY TO
BRING FIND OUT OF THE TWO.
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE
ROLE NOW FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ON ALL ITEMS.
BLOOM I.
WITH IT.
THAT WAS EASY.
WORD YEARNED